Boom,
and we're live.
Why are you calling?
I'm alright.
How are you going on?
A lot of stuff happening,
man.
Yeah,
yeah.
First of all,
thank you so much.
Pleasure.
This is amazing.
Well,
Dave Rubin recommends you.
I listened to Dave Room is.
I don't want to send a whole lot of
people's recommendations,
but Dave Rubin's one of them.
He's been an amazing figure in my life.
Just in the last lesson,
even a month.
And he just,
he's kind of was like my savior when
like everyone was kicking me while I was
down.
He was the one that kind of reached a
handout and so I owe him a great deal.
Well,
we should kind of explain what kicking
you while you're down means because it's
silly to me than anything because it
doesn't really make sense,
but you tweeted a joke and it's a real
simple joke.
Jamie,
see if he could pull up the joke.
This is what happened.
Collin tweeted a joke about a day
without a woman and uh,
everybody knows that a day without what,
without a woman was like that day
without a Mexican thing where you were
supposed to like,
well,
imagine if there were no women.
Well,
if there were no women,
first of all,
there'd be no fucking people.
So yeah.
Yes.
Women are super important for.
So you just write this tweet joke,
a peace and quiet hashtag a day without
a woman.
I would laugh.
I would think it was funny and I would
move on and that's it.
So then all the,
hold on a second,
put put,
put that Olivia,
look,
go above that,
go above that.
Above it.
We'll get that.
Sent this tweet,
which was roundly condemned as sexist.
Yeah.
Not really true if you leave the gaming
industry,
but a rapidly condemned in the gaming
industry for sure.
Outside of that,
people I think normal everyday,
people that don't have an ax to grind
about literally everything found it,
you know,
reddit maybe growing or maybe laughed
and then kept going about their day.
Like a normal person.
You're not allowed to have any
personality anymore.
No.
If you work for any kind of accompany
that is in any way public where you can
be targeted,
where they can say,
oh,
that's the fucking God.
Go get them.
Like anything that's remotely
controversial.
I mean that is a really remotely
It's just Al Bundy.
Yeah,
I mean it's not even a good joke.
And,
and uh,
you know,
yeah.
It's,
I,
I heard you and Jim Norton talking about
it by the way,
that video that someone clipped that out
and put it up on some youtube channel
that's like a,
that video is going to be irrelevant.
My family forever.
Everyone was like,
I can't believe this.
What is going on?
This is so great so far.
I really do appreciate you stepping up.
And when I got your DM,
by the way on twitter,
I was like,
this is what an amazing turn of events
this has been for me.
So I,
I really am appreciative of you.
Again,
I want you to know that.
Thank you.
Stop saying it makes me uncomfortable.
But uh,
but uh,
at the same time,
uh,
you know,
I,
I was in bed with my girlfriend actually
when I wrote it and I showed it to her
and I was like,
this is kind of funny,
right?
It's kind of stupid.
And she laughed.
She,
she's an er nurse and she works the
overnight shift so she was just getting
into bed as I was getting up and she's
like,
yeah,
it was funny.
Then we didn't really think twice about
it.
I sent it,
I got in the shower,
I went about my day and uh,
and then when I got to work I realized
that it was a much bigger deal than I
had thought and it was,
and then everything fell apart and then
it was rebuilt very quickly.
So.
Well
you resigned from the company that you
worked for?
Yeah,
I found that I founded the company I
owned a piece of.
And you resigned because of that?
Yeah,
yeah.
Other reasons too.
But I mean that was definitely the straw
that broke the camel's back for me yet.
What in the fuck,
man?
Yeah,
it was just,
I felt like,
how is it,
how is it possible that in this day and
age,
that simple tweet,
by the way,
if you reverse the sexes in that tweet,
there's not a single man that would
complain and if he did,
he's not a man.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I say also that if a person that
wasn't a self described like moderate
conservative or libertarian sent that
joke,
it also wouldn't have gotten the
firestorm.
That's the thing Joe,
is that you don't think a liberal man
wouldn't have gotten a rash of shit and
been sort of,
I think out of the community maybe in a
different maybe in a different place,
but not in the gaming industry,
which is almost completely hyper
liberal.
So I've had a target on my back for
years and that's I think kind of the
point that's lost on some people is that
this was just an opportunity.
No one was offended by this joke.
No one was a gas,
like I said on Rubin,
and the second time I was on there I
said like no one was crying in their
shower,
losing sleep,
tossing and turning over.
They had shown was,
well,
I hope so because that's what we should
find that person and that person is
studied them in a lab.
But to me I was like,
no,
this is.
I mean,
it was,
it was clear.
A few hours later when I finally
realized what was happening,
I'm like,
this is,
they're in for the kill now.
This is,
this is.
They found their way to get me.
And so why do you think they wanted to
quote unquote get you?
Uh,
because,
you know,
I live in San Francisco.
I've lived there for 10 years.
I was born and raised on long island,
but I went to college in Boston and then
I moved to San Francisco and um,
it is as cartoonishly liberal as
everyone thinks it is.
So it's,
it's,
and the gaming industry is there,
the gaming media,
the people that write about games and
cover them and do all that kind of stuff
there.
They're largely there and it's a huge
echo chamber.
They don't like when people penetrate
the Echo Chamber and uh,
I made a name for myself in the industry
over years.
I was the senior editor of the biggest
gaming website in the world for years,
but websites,
[inaudible] dot com.
And uh,
and I was the senior editor there and
uh,
I made a name for myself,
not only with criticism and with long
form pieces but,
but,
but basically I was writing pieces about
political correctness in 2011 and 2012
people going after game developers.
People going after all these things and
me kind of standing up and saying,
this isn't okay.
This character assassination.
A good example for everyone out there
that doesn't know games.
There's this game called borderlands
two.
One of the developers was giving an
interview about it.
He,
uh,
and this was back in I think 2011.
He said something to the nature of this
mode.
This particular mode in the game is
accessible for everyone.
It's like a girlfriend mode if you want
your girlfriend to come play.
This was like a.
He said,
girl,
he insinuated that women can't play
games and don't know how to play games
where everybody using the term
girlfriend when people went after this
guy and tried to get them,
you know,
and I,
I wrote this piece saying like,
what the Hell is everyone doing?
This guy just is trying to explain
something,
he's not as sexist.
Why do you make these assumptions based
on this one thing about him and why do
you want to ruin someone?
And that's the whole thing.
They want to ruin people.
So I was outspoken about this and I was
outspoken for my supportive Mitt Romney
and I was outspoken about my sport for
Gary Johnson and my house book.
So they don't like that.
They don't like that stuff.
And,
and,
uh,
I think that's pretty clear now.
So you feel like there's a sort of a
reinforced type of thinking,
like a very liberal,
reinforced type of thinking that you
must subscribe to if you want to be a
part of this?
Yes.
It's an orthodoxy.
It's a complete and utter orthodoxy and
it's,
it's what's so nice about this,
like the unintended consequence that I
think is the silver lining of the dark
cloud is people from the outside.
Now Saul firsthand,
like what I had been saying for a long
time,
which was,
which was like I was kind of on the
fringe.
I was kind of being pushed out and I got
out literally thousands of people
tweeting.
I mean facebook message me and doing
everything being like,
wow,
this is fucking crazy.
These people really are out to get you.
Based on that,
you know,
you would think,
uh,
I,
I said some horrible,
just offensive,
just truly awful thing.
Do you think they're really out to get
you or do you think they're capitalizing
on a moment where they feel like you
have a target on you and they'll like
kick him?
He's down.
We got them and some days,
but this reaction culture that we have
like this over overreaction culture that
we find ourself in today,
it really does seem to foster that kind
of behavior that people really like it
when someone gets caught doing something
or when someone says something
inappropriate when you could just point
the finger and then everybody can pile
on.
Yeah,
I think,
well let me put it a different way
because I think you're probably right in
a sense in the sense that I.
I never gained the benefit of the doubt
with this group.
Let's put it that way.
Right.
So.
So it was one thing.
It was just the one thing that dominoes
there was tipped and it was in that and
they were down as opposed to.
That's why I brought up the example
before of if one of the people that they
actually liked within that insular
industry said the same thing.
They might have been a gas but they may
might have reached a handout or given
that person a second chance.
So I think that that all plays into the,
you know,
I have it the Gadsden flag as my
twitter,
I kind of had that first,
since 2009.
I am,
you know,
I've not been shots and flag being don't
tread on one of the snake.
Right,
exactly.
Um,
uh,
so there are just certain things that
may be very different than other people
in the industry.
And I think that I definitely think that
that plays a.
what's your twitter name is no taxation,
which is a reference to the American
revolution,
which I know,
you know,
a lot of people think,
well,
no,
no taxes.
I'm like,
that's not what it means.
I can't,
I can't fit no taxation without
representation on twitter.
That's why it doesn't say that.
Yeah,
that would be a long ass.
Yeah.
Unnecessarily long.
You'd have no room for tweets,
but it would make you very economical
with your words.
That's what I love about twitter.
You probably feel the same way.
I write something really long sometimes.
Then I have to Parse it and figure out
how to make it fit.
And it feels so very good for joke
writing,
like for,
for the skill of joke writing to make to
make things more concise.
Like I always tell people that I think
the greatest joke writer or the greatest
comedian is Joey Diaz because he says he
gives you the most amount of visuals and
impact with the least amount of words.
It's just ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba ba.
He knows how to like sink it in really
quickly.
And twitter's like a good tool for that.
But not if that's a little ridiculous.
That's because you only back.
I don't know if that's the case how it
is now,
but we'll actually.
It definitely is.
Right?
Like if I write to you,
if I reply to you,
your name takes up a big chunk of what
tweet for you,
but what you tweet doesn't take up.
So it's like the 140 characters would be
limiting people that respond to you
rather than you tweeting.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the beauty is to,
as you've probably noticed,
is that I think in the last year or
whatever,
they images you have to take up
characters too and the videos and links
and I think the links are the only thing
left that takes up the extra characters
in addition to the name,
but it keeps everyone,
Kurt.
But that doesn't stop people from
tweeting 7,000 times in a row and put
numbers on them.
I've done it too.
Yeah,
I know I did it just yesterday when I
ran into some woman in San Francisco
that I was walking my dog.
I have a Boston terrier.
She was like a little sicker.
Her poop was a little wet so I went and
picked it up and I left like,
you know,
just like smear,
you'd have to use your fingernails to
get off the ground.
So the woman came out of her apartment
and started scolding me.
Like she was waiting by the,
by the window to scold me for this.
And I like,
what the Hell is going on?
So I had to tweet out a few tweets about
that just for it.
For posterity.
Yeah,
to the twitter thing is very weird,
but here's something that I really don't
like and I'm glad I don't see much of it
anymore.
Is that twit longer?
Shit.
Hey,
that's a loophole.
Yeah,
we don't do that.
Don't do that.
Ralphie may's do that shit all the time.
He used to read his tweets.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Ralphie,
while you're writing paragraphs here,
you know what's going on?
Yeah.
Some people,
you know,
I've done it to a put.
We'll like go in in photoshop and make a
paragraph of text and then make that the
image that you will do that on instagram
too.
Oh yeah,
I've done that before.
I've drawn written things down and then
taking a photo.
I said I was going to do that for
awhile.
That I think that twitter is just too
impersonal.
I'm going to write all my stuff out and
then take a picture of it,
but I was just fucking around.
I think if that's the exception,
the exception,
I think it's totally fine.
I don't want people to ruin in twitter.
I like the Curtis.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
It's good format,
but it also makes it extremely easy for
people to do what happened to you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because there are nuances lost,
right?
Yeah.
He wants his last.
Well,
it's always lost in text.
I mean,
we're in writing.
It's very difficult.
Even if you're reading a book,
sometimes you have to go over the
previous paragraphs.
We'll figure out exactly how this guy
was setting this up,
but I think what's.
What's happening,
what you're saying.
I see there's two parts of one.
The example you gave before about the
guy saying that like girlfriend mode,
if he just said,
it's like say if your girlfriend doesn't
play video games and she wants to really
easily accessible,
you could do it that way,
but I'd be.
People probably would attack them even
for that.
It would say,
what are you implying that girls don't
play video games?
Well,
that's the impulse.
It's always the implication,
right?
Like everyone's always out to assume the
absolute worst announced.
We're always trying to write about like
this guy is just trying to make an
example.
He's probably given 15 pr interviews
today.
He's probably exhausted.
He is also a developer so he doesn't
have much PR training.
He's trying to just get the point
across.
Why do you have to assume the man is a
sexist and a messages because of this
one thing.
It,
it,
it's,
I'm willing to die on that hill because
I feel like people deserve the benefit
of the doubt.
People deserve to make a mistake or get
a joke wrong or you know,
all those kinds of things.
And I feel like yes,
people are allowed to exercise their
free speech on the other enemy.
Like I don't like that joke or I don't
like this or I don't like that,
but it's,
it doesn't stop there
with what's going on with Dave Chappelle
this week.
I thought it was really actually
interesting.
Uh,
with his two specials on Netflix.
People were freaking out about,
you know,
his jokes,
his,
his jokes about gay people or
transgender people wherever.
Well as comparing transgender people to
black people and you know,
and saying that it's a ridiculous
comparison,
right?
Like,
like I,
I actually,
after I saw the,
all the,
all the stuff I went and watched the
first one that I watched half of the
second one and I was falling asleep so I
didn't want to watch it anymore,
but I was like,
this is funny.
And uh,
uh,
Anthony Jeselnik or Daniel tosh would
make these people shit their pants
compared to the,
to what's going on with this kind of
stuff.
And it's always this drama that seeks to
kind of,
it,
it doesn't stop at saying like,
I don't like it.
It's often insinuated or outright spoken
that they want to censor it or change
it.
That's where I am because I was reading
a piece specifically about chappelle
where they're like,
this guy calls up questions as to why,
like how far should comedy go?
And I'm like,
no,
that doesn't,
that doesn't call.
And that's when the free speech argument
ends for me.
That's what I'm like.
You're actually now talking about
changing it.
Well,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't work with US
comics.
It just doesn't work.
We're not going to do it.
It's too many people like it.
And I understand what they're trying to
do because when they live in that world
of cubicles and human resources and very
restricted patterns of behavior that you
have to follow,
if you live in an office environment and
working in an office environment or
other,
you know,
there's a lot of people out there that
are boxed into these terrible situations
where you have to pretend to be this
thing that you're not and you again,
you don't have any personality,
you don't.
You're not allowed to say anything
ridiculous or silly.
And when you,
you have that kind of environment and
you see someone who's free,
like Dave Chappelle,
you,
you want to stop it.
And if you can,
if you can point something out that can,
oh look,
he's saying something that's
inappropriate.
He's saying something I don't agree
with.
He's saying something.
Let's get them,
let's go get them.
And then also in defense of the writers
that are writing these articles,
look,
they're in a bizarre environment where
they have to fucking constantly defend
like their position.
They have to constantly get clicks.
They have to constantly get hits.
They can't just put an article out and
nobody reads it.
They'll lose their job,
so they have to write about something
that's inflammatory,
write about something that's salacious,
something that's going to get people
excited.
I mean that guy that wrote that thing
about you for the International Business
Times.
I looked into that international
business times and one of the things
about it is that there was a.
I think it was a mother Jones article
about that website where they were told
that the people who write articles were
given some ridiculous task like they
have to get 10,000 hits per article.
They write,
so that might have for people don't
know.
There was a guy who wrote an article
about Collin where it said kind of
funnies.
Collin Moriarty was resigns after
writing a joke,
a racist joke that targeted women.
It wasn't racist,
even remote in the slightest,
but when you take into account the
environment that these people are forced
work in and
you say,
well,
this guy literally,
it's forced to write something that's
more fucked up than it really is.
So you have to get people excited about
this.
In a way that's going to get them to
click on it and hopefully get him to his
10,000 hit quota.
If that is true,
I feel for him in a way I feel.
I mean I think he's working for a shitty
business,
but it's the same way I feel.
I mean,
I,
I actually,
you know,
I came from the editorial world where
you have to get clear.
I mean we were getting,
our expectations were way higher.
And um,
did you have those kind of requirements?
No,
no,
not literally.
I know some sites do,
but both sides have all your quota,
a quota or like you get bonuses if you
get a certain amount of hits or
whatever.
And we didn't have that.
We were salaried or whatever,
but you would be fired ultimately if you
weren't writing things that people were
reading.
But I tried to stay out of my way for
writing inflammatory things.
Actually there are a couple of examples
where I wouldn't write a story because I
felt like it wasn't pertinent to any
information and it was specifically to
assassinate someone's character when we
found a problem.
Here you have fucking morals,
dude.
Where's the door?
Like no room in this business.
I had a,
I had a high,
a high profile woman in the gaming
industry.
Tell me in an interview that was
unrelated to what I was actually
interviewing her that she'd never was
once the victim of sexism in the
industry ever.
And that was,
and I was like,
I could write this,
but this isn't why I was there to,
you know,
I wasn't interviewing her about this and
this is going to cause her problems and
that's not who I am.
I don't.
I caused her problem because then people
are going to.
Then people are gonna jump on and be
like,
well,
you know,
I experienced this,
I experienced this and you're
diminishing and we'll just cause her
drama.
I'm like,
why would I do that?
It's not.
See,
this is where it drives me crazy.
That's a beautiful example of people
being cool if she can say,
Hey,
I've never experienced any sexism in his
business.
You'd be like,
wow,
the gaming industry must be really cool
and this woman has managed to get
through the maze with a bunch of high
fives and people appreciating her work.
Wouldn't that be celebrated?
Not In the gaming and you know what I'm
saying?
Like why does that have to be in some
ways a target like why is that story at
target?
Like wouldn't you assume that if there
is a person who can reach a high level
of prominence in this very complicated
business,
right.
I mean the gaming industry is incredibly
complicated,
especially how weighted everything is
when it comes to male versus female
stuff.
That whole Gamergate shit exposed so
much of that,
which was really confusing to people in
the outside.
Especially people like me who don't play
games.
Right.
I was like,
what in the fucking shooting these gamer
people.
Yeah.
It's confusing to me too.
I mean the,
the second story,
I think it was more pertinent though,
which was this guy had this guy worked
at a big publisher.
He was and he was laid off and he had
like this huge meltdown on social media
and people were writing about it and I
was like,
I knew him personally and not wasn't
really friendly with them at the time,
but I knew him personally and I was
like,
and reverence that we should write about
this,
and I'm like,
what is this?
What is the serving?
Like,
what was the meltdown?
He just,
he just had,
he was just going off about how he was
just angry and sad.
He's a young kid that finally got in and
then he his grip on
the,
on the job and was and was laid off,
whatever,
and he's fine now he's back in the
industry,
but the.
I was like,
I think I wasn't cut out to be like this
hard core,
like don't get them journalism like at
any cost because I was like,
this is going to ruin this.
Like why would I want to contribute to
this,
to this,
to this.
I didn't get into this industry to,
to the pile on people to ruin their
lives.
I got into this industry to celebrate
video games,
to tell interesting stories about games,
to challenge people's minds and I always
tried to take that with me where I was
like,
I'm not going to write anything for the
clicks I could.
I could,
I could write.
These ladies had salacious headlines,
a I can write this,
this,
this dirt or this,
this stuff.
I heard whatever,
but that's not who I am.
That's not who I want to be,
and I'd rather contribute more
positively to,
to the ecosystem.
Then then be like,
well,
I'll just get clicks for this today and
this guy has got to read the story and
it's going to be in Google and Lexis
nexis forever and it's going to,
for what?
So I can get 50,000 clicks one day and
then just move on.
He's not gonna be able to move on.
He didn't even do anything that is
worthy of being writing about.
We writing about this.
Why are we always after people while
you're mindset is noble?
I mean,
it is a great way to look at things.
It's,
it's weird that it's so unusual,
you know,
and that most people would be more self
serving and would choose the path going
to get them the most clicks and hey,
I've got a fucking crack,
a few eggs to make an omelet.
That's how it goes.
Yeah.
And that's not because I don't want,
I never wanted the Canon to be turned on
me even though it was eventually.
You don't know what I mean.
The cat hates like the try to put out
that energy that you want,
that's,
that's positive or at least
constructive.
If someone like murder someone in the
gaming industry.
Yes.
That's noteworthy.
We should probably write about that if
someone just depends on who they're
murdered.
Right.
Well,
what do you mean when someone's a
terrible person that murdered them?
Like punisher style?
Well,
that's different.
I guess we can.
We can have that conversation I guess.
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're saying,
man.
I agree with you.
It's,
it's again,
it's knowable.
What would your mindset,
your philosophy is very noble and I wish
more people shared it and I think that
when there's all these people scrambling
around like we're seeing now and you
know,
trying to find their niche and trying to
get attention and you find more of that
kind of a predatory behavior.
Yeah,
I agree as well.
That brings me back to what we were
saying specifically about we feel bad
for these writers at these sites and to
me like the analogy I draw is like I
hate the Tsa,
right?
There's normal people that work for the
TSA that are just trying to do their
thing,
but that doesn't mean I don't hate the
system that they work under and think
the system should change and it's the
same thing here.
It's like these.
Yeah,
these guys are victimized by the set of
circumstances in which they under which
they have to write,
but that doesn't mean that the system
should remain the same because they need
to write those stories.
Talk about the TSA because I don't know
more about that than I know about
business or about your business rather.
Sure.
Like what,
what do you hate about the Tsa?
They're infringing on your fourth
amendment rights.
The warrantless searches a day legally
sees things.
I mean,
this is written very clearly in the bill
of rights.
So,
and I hate the whole argument of like,
well,
you,
you don't have,
you know,
are you,
you,
um,
you kind of pass by your rights or give
them up when you're in the airport.
And I'm like,
no,
they're,
they're inalienable actually.
So I just have a huge problem.
I don't have a problem going through a
metal detector or something reasonable.
A reasonable search.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's kind of reasonable because there
are carbon fiber blades and all these
different plastic blades that they can
make now that you could really fuck
somebody up that are,
I'm not going to show up in a metal
detector.
Sure.
But it goes back to the first of all,
you know,
I don't think that we're going to have
many problems on airplanes anymore.
I think that they're moving,
moving onto something else and no plane
is going to get hijacked.
And now that everyone knows what's going
to happen.
But Dude,
as soon as you think like that,
that's when something happens.
That's,
that can be,
that can be a relevant argument.
I also wanna give a shout out that
serious things happen.
My Dad's in New York,
a retired New York City firefighter.
So it's,
it's quit.
Very cool.
I knew people that died that day,
but it's still,
you know,
and my dad could have died that day
depending on the circumstances.
Thank God he didn't.
But to me it was like I just would.
Right.
It's like the old Benjamin Franklin
thing,
you know,
it's balancing,
uh,
your,
your liberty,
your freedom with security.
And I think that we've,
we've,
we've given them so much power with
Patriot Act,
with the Tsa,
with all these things where I'm like,
this is a bad road to go to,
to go down and they're just going to
take more and more.
So yeah.
What is the Benjamin Franklin quote?
He who value safety over.
Yeah,
over over liberty deserves neither
safety nor liberty.
Yeah.
I think the TSA has a ridiculously hard
job.
And I think the requirements that people
have,
the what,
what people request of them to make sure
that they're safe and then you give them
$10 an hour or whatever the fuck they
make,
they don't make much.
Of course you get is a bunch of
underqualified people who are tired and
they're tired of working like the
constant flow.
If you watch how I like to study people
at the airport because I feel like it's
one of the rare times where you could
just stare at people while they're doing
their job and no one gets weird with you
because everybody staring at that guy or
that girl that's taking your license and
scanning your ticket and all that jazz.
So I just stare at him and I watch how
they,
how they interact with all these people
and people are fucking tired.
That's what I see.
I see.
I see frustration.
I see so many people in these lines and
I see people just being exhausted.
And then the people that have to deal
with the people that don't take their
shoes off.
Sorry,
you have to take your shoes out.
Why would I take my shoes off?
Take your fucking shoes off man.
You see that kind of thinking,
right?
It just there on the edge all the time.
So you're not dealing with them.
We'll start taking shoes off because
it's going through this thing.
It's not like he has one guy's dealing
with short whole day.
He's dealing with this constant river of
human beings that are coming through and
some of them have water bottles and you
got to make sure those dangerous water
bottles don't get on the plane.
There's a lot of stupid shit that goes
with the TSA,
but how the fuck else are you going to
keep people from bringing shoe bombs or
knives on planes and it's really hard to
do.
No,
it is I,
I mean I don't,
I don't think that the,
the,
the counterpoint would be to just get
rid of it.
You just walk into a terminal and be
able to get on an airplane.
But I remember,
you know,
remember too,
and a lot of people do.
We had a security apparatus before nine,
11.
These guys out smarter this security
apparatus by doing very specific things,
including like knowing how to fly planes
and doing all the things that you can't
possibly check for and also people get
guns and knives and weapons
intentionally through the,
through the Tsa all the time to I think
wasn't it something like over 90 percent
of agents that we're trying to get
through things through the TSA
succeeded.
So these are,
these are the people standing in between
us and isis.
People do it accidentally all the time.
They have stuff in their bag and it gets
through and then they go,
what the fuck?
You know?
I mean it happens all the time.
Yeah.
I knew a guy that,
that brought a ton of weed overseas on
accident,
you know,
like that's terrifying.
Like here's a shit like me too.
Like I go through my bed just for
anything you might leave in there and
your,
the expert.
I always come through just make sure
there's nothing,
you know,
you never know what's going to happen,
but to the point he didn't mean to do
that.
Right.
But it was there,
it was.
So yeah.
It's,
it's not a perfect system and it's not
going to be,
and that's just the way it is.
It would be nice if it was more
efficient.
It would be nice that people got paid
better.
It'd be nice if it was easier and
quicker.
There'd be a lot of.
It would be nice,
but I don't know of anybody that's come
up with a better system for scanning
people and making sure that they don't
bring guns or bombs or whatever the fuck
it is on an airplane.
It's just bizarre that airplanes are the
one place where we have so much fucking
security were malls which are filled
with way more people than your average
plane.
There's something about terror and
flying where it's already terrifying,
like,
yeah,
you think you're scared now,
bitch,
what if it blows up in the fucking guy?
Dude pulls a fucking turbine out of his
bag and wraps around his head and starts
lightened his underwear on fire.
You know?
That's.
That's what we're scared of.
We're scared of someone taking it to the
next level because people are already
tensed.
Yeah,
because you're in a metal tube hurling
through the sky at 500 miles an hour.
If it blows up while you're doing that,
it's even more freaky.
Oh my God.
It's horrifying.
Let me a weird.
It's terrifying,
but it's kind of strange.
Whereas like that seems to be like the
preferred method of terror like that
we're really worried about which is why
the TSA exist in the first place because
the volume of humans that go through a
lot of places,
it's probably commensurate with the
volume of humans that go through the
airport.
Oh sure.
You don't have a single place that you
could mention that's as strict with what
you carry around as the airport.
You could walk into the fucking mall
with a loaded gun any day of the week,
any day of the week.
Every single time I walk on the mall,
I am just never checked.
Nobody.
Nobody frisks me.
I don't go there.
Any metal detectors.
You could walk in arm to the fucking
teeth and that.
Who's going to stop you?
The mall security guard.
The Fuck Outta here and his little.
His little sub during Christmas time,
there are thousands of people at the
mall.
Thousands,
thousands and thousands.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean that's,
it's like it's more like the Israeli
experience where I like this.
This kind of shit can happen at any time
anywhere and they're very vigilant about
that.
I've often wondered that as well,
like why doesn't even at a security
checkpoint in a,
in an airport,
why not just do what they're like?
And I really think it's that they,
you know,
to your point with the mall and all
these kinds of things in the public
places,
I think it just speaks to the fact that
most people,
a vast majority people are just good,
decent people that want to go about
their lives for sure.
And that these terrorists could target
all of these different places.
I don't think they do.
Maybe because they can't,
but probably more because they don't
want to
give themselves away for something that
might be seen as minor.
Like,
like nine slash 11 was a spectacle.
It wasn't only that 3000 some odd people
died.
It was that.
It was the spectacle of killing those
people in that way and so I think that
there's something about that as well,
which is why I'm more scared about like
a dirty bomb or something like that
today than I am of anyone taking an
airplane over because everyone knows
what happened in 2001.
So now someone pulls out a knife on an
airplane and try.
Someone's just going to tackle that guy
and probably kill him.
That's why I'm not sure.
That's why the guy.
Yeah,
I know the guy tried to blow his shoe up
or something like that on the plane.
That's why we have to take our shoes off
now.
But uh,
yeah.
To me I'm like the,
the,
the threat has changed that the threat
is evolving and we can be vigilant in
all these ways,
but then I wonder it's,
it goes back to like Nsa and all these
things like how much are we going to
give the government and how much are we
going to give up in order for safety?
I'd rather live in a more dangerous
world first,
personally,
and know that no one's reading my text
messages or no one's throwing out my
hand lotion or harassing.
I saw these,
these two women,
Australian women in the airport at Sfo.
When I came down to La last week,
they were in wheelchairs.
They were going through all of their
stuff and like.
And I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing to these
people?
I just leave them alone and I actually
went up to them afterwards and I'm like,
I'm sorry.
We hate these people too.
Just so you know.
So this is not okay with any of us that
were there.
They were there for like a half an hour
ago.
They had these frowns on their faces.
They looked dejected.
This might be their first time in the
states for all I know or predict map.
Here's what happens.
You come over here,
check your shit,
take your pants off.
When he got in there,
it's like,
what are you packing?
The harassing old women?
They're harassing,
harassing.
I,
I think I saw in jfk once,
like going through like a nun's bang or
something like,
what?
This is madness to me,
I'm like,
this is not everyone's turning on each
other,
but it's not because if it wasn't,
if they didn't go through everyone
thoroughly and they,
oh,
we're going to let nuns go through.
And then what happened?
Somebody dressed as a nun and they act
as a terrorist or they are a terrorist.
I liked the,
uh,
someone that I don't know much about it,
you probably know more about it than I
do,
but someone was telling me a little bit
about the Israel,
the way the Israelis do airport security
specifically that it's,
they,
it's like all about,
uh,
it's,
they're not profiling,
but even based on race or anything,
they're profiling based on your
behavior.
And it goes to your point like these are
well paid professional people that know
what the fuck they're doing,
know what they're looking for and
they're in the airport and they see
someone just acting a little weird and
they also do some crazy shit.
Like,
I had a friend who went there and she
took photos of um,
some,
uh,
antisemetic a pictures,
some like Nazi swastikas on something.
So,
you know what the Israeli guys did at
the airport.
They shot her computer and they gave it
back.
Really?
Yes.
She's.
Yeah.
So there's,
that's a little over the top.
Yeah.
So there's that a little more balanced
than that.
Can we see you a computer.
And they opened up her computer.
Terrible Israeli accent.
Not even know where to go with it there.
I just put a fucking hoe she heard dunk
dunk and they gave her back her fucking
computer.
That's a half hour later.
That's,
that's some,
that's a little too strong for me.
But uh,
to your point,
to the point like,
I don't know what this is,
I just don't like the security theater
aspect of it.
We all know what's going on.
Everyone's being inconvenienced.
These people are miserable.
We're miserable.
It's just,
it goes back down to no one wants to
make
hard decisions or I'll even do what,
like really hard work.
Like what works,
what doesn't,
let's do studies.
Let's figure out what,
what we're doing instead of looking at
people naked and machines and will you
also have to take the,
well,
you don't really see anyone naked
machines anymore.
That's not real.
I know,
but back in the day,
but even back in the day it was just
like,
come on man.
What are you worried about?
What people are so silly?
Worried about people seeing me naked.
But the,
the,
the um,
the thing that gets to me though is
like,
how can you make it safer?
No one has offered up any sort of an
alternative to the TSA that makes any
sense to me.
I mean,
I've heard people say the Tsh and
competent,
I fucking hate them.
They no violation of fourth amendment,
but there's no,
there's no alternatives that I've seen
that they're even remotely responsible.
No,
I mean I,
I think it goes back to me of like,
I can't speak necessarily to the level
of competence because I'm not
insecurity.
I don't know.
Like what specifically do.
I don't know what their level of
training is.
It just goes back to the
constitutionality of it.
Like if we,
if we,
and it brings up those tough questions,
it's the same way I feel about about the
second amendment.
If we start seeding what this means in
certain situations,
then before you know it,
they'll just continue to erode it away.
Like,
and um,
so when I'm like,
this is a warrantless search,
this is by definition a warrantless
search.
If you went and got John Jay and James
Madison and all these guys and ask the
and somehow told them what the fuck was
going on.
And then instead like what does this
look like this.
But you would have to go and get them
and then go,
okay,
this is isis and this is the internet.
And then this was twitter and this is a,
this is how they send information
through pictures with Metadata,
you know,
it's encoded in the picture and you have
to break it down.
And that's where the message is.
Like,
they'd be like,
oh yeah,
search everybody that be my God.
You live in a terrible place to be.
I got to go to bed and really processed
this.
Like back in the day when we only had
muskets,
it was so awesome.
I don't know if my argument makes sense
to you but it,
but to me it's,
I just feel like these are certain
sacred rights that need to be protected
in any way they can.
And if we want to have a conversation
about like,
why we should see this right in this
specific way,
then you have to do it a little more
clearly.
And to me I,
I just,
I think people take some of these things
for granted that,
you know,
what's stopping them from,
if,
if these rights continue to erode,
then what stops them from busing in your
house at some point and be like,
well,
we all,
they can do that.
And there,
there are some search and seizure
methods that they're,
they're really being criticized for
lately in particular for these,
uh,
for drug offenses where they just don't
even knock.
They just break open people's doors and
wind up shooting their dogs all the
time.
Shoot people all the time.
I mean there was an article written
recently about the amount of people that
are wounded in unnecessary,
like how do they describe that kind of
altercation between the cops?
No knock,
no search lists.
Warrant or what is the.
I think they just call it no knock break
ins or something like that.
I don't.
I don't know how to describe it,
but if you've seen the way the dea
treats any sort of situation,
even when they just have marijuana,
they'll kick down the door.
If they see a dog,
they shoot it and then they,
they,
they make people huddled up in the
corner after they just murdered your
family pet and oftentimes they find like
a pipe.
You know what I mean?
There's many people that had been called
a on like someone has turned them in or
someone has a said something about them
and it turned out to not be true.
Like,
Hey,
these people have a grow up and their
business or in their house rather,
and one of them was a former FBI,
a couple that both worked in the FBI.
They kicked in their fucking door,
held them at gunpoint,
the whole deal.
Went to the basement.
They were growing tomatoes and they were
like,
what in the fuck?
These are retired FBI officers and the
dea broke down their door and pointed a
loaded gun in their face and then found
plants.
Yeah,
you can eat that.
You can eat,
you can eat.
We do as they can.
It's actually not bad for you.
I,
uh,
so these things are happening actually.
That one thing sounds familiar with the
family pet being killed.
I think I saw a video on that.
A lot of it.
It's not just one thing,
men,
one of them was a mayor and um,
God dammit.
Was it Washington?
Where was it?
There was a mayor who the.
It turned out that the post office,
someone in the post office was running a
scam.
And what they were doing was they were
having,
we'd sent to other people's addresses
and they were sending it through the
post office and the postman would
intercept the package because he was the
guy who delivered that out of drugs.
So he would get that package and somehow
or another it got intercepted before it
got to the post man and then they had a
dummy post man come and bring it and
then do the whole break down the door.
Shoot the dog thing.
They chased the dog,
a golden lab,
chased them out in the yard.
The dog ran and it was running and
hiding and they shot him in front of
everybody.
It turned out that the guy who was the
victim of this and his family who were
held at gunpoint and zip tied,
it was a mayor and so you know,
he was like,
what in the fuck are you people doing?
Like,
what is this?
You just killed my dog in front of my
kids.
You traumatized my family.
Yeah,
it's awful.
But you're making the argument in my
opinion of why we have to take a stand,
you know,
like why we have to say like in this,
in that situation,
yes,
but just not tsa though.
No,
but it's.
But it is a fourth amendment issue that
we would that or allow them to be
eroding.
No one should be allowed to go into
anyone's home without a warrant no
matter what,
but don't you think that you sort of
imply at least a certain amount of
consent when you get in that line and
give them your bag and say,
here,
search this,
like no one's telling you that you have
to do that.
You could choose to fly with no baggage
at all.
You could choose if you want to send
your stuff through the mail and it would
probably cost the same amount as it
would to pay that 50 bucks or whatever
it is with southwest.
If you wanted to send your package
through the mail,
you could do it that way and just walk
through with nothing on you.
Sure you could do that.
Yeah,
and you would still have to go through
the machines and all that.
I don't.
I don't dispute that because I agree
with you in the pre nine slash 11 world.
I'm going through the metal detector.
Having your bags and you're looking at
it through the machine.
I think that that's all reasonable.
I just don't like the people being
pulled aside.
Pulled in the rooms,
people just going through the kind of
very disrespectfully going through shit
and I don't know how to connect to me.
I have,
I,
I just.
Is that,
is that a hill worth dying on?
In a way?
It is because I feel like it could just
as you made the point,
it's already see that mentality now
seeps into of different places.
Right?
And I just don't want to see what the.
I don't want to see the end result of
that.
You know,
that mentality is also the justification
for the NSA.
Being able to look at your text messages
or being able to look at your emails and
that's the big thing that was exposed by
Edward Snowden.
That really pissed me off that so many
people are so flippant about.
They were like,
Hey,
if you're not doing anything wrong,
don't worry about it.
Like that is wrong.
You can't say that because you can't
look at everyone.
You can't just randomly look at everyone
and look at their private information.
You just can't do that because the
people that are looking at that are just
people.
And that's the problem with the TSA.
It's not even necessarily the issue
being that you get to search people
stuff to make sure there's no terrorists
and no people bringing weapons on a
planet.
It's who gets to do that.
Who are these people?
Are these people experts or these
people's security experts?
Are they,
are they work for the massage?
You know,
are they,
uh,
are they CIA agents or they FBI?
Are they,
who's looking?
Who these people are they competent?
Why are they doing when you go to the
airport,
man,
you see what you see is a bunch of
people.
And I used to joke about this,
that I think that phrase,
this making sound less insulting than it
used to be the old joke.
But the idea was that I think that the
people that work at Burger King at the
airport and the TSA,
they're the same people and they just
reach into a hat today.
I got fries.
Oh Shit,
I'm on duty.
It's literally almost like that.
It's like you see people that are just
taking whatever job they can get ahold
of,
you know,
I feel for them.
I mean if someone comes along and you
don't have a job and they say,
hey,
the Tsa Siren,
15 bucks an hour.
Okay,
cool.
What I gotta do you gotta stand here and
make sure that people don't bring water
bottles on a plane.
All right.
And then after like the 50th day,
if people bring them in,
take your fucking water bottle out of
the bag.
No,
you're doing.
Yeah.
My,
my frustration grows in that way,
which is people that in 2017 seemed to
have some because you and I,
I'm sure you do too.
I fly all the time.
Right.
So you,
you see all types.
Right.
And it's like you always encountered the
guys like have you not flown in the last
15 years ever to know that people try to
walk through the machines with their
shoes on their belt.
It's like what is the time?
And then the convenience get people that
don't push their bins through the,
you know,
down to the thing and just leave it
there for someone else to push through.
Like what is going on?
People are just couldn't.
There was this one guy was really kind
of funny,
he was going through the metal detector
thing and he had a bottle of water in
his bag and because he had a bottle of
water in his bag there to check his bag.
And so,
um,
when he goes through,
they set your bag aside,
you know,
your thing goes through line that hits
the scanner and they said they pull it
back check.
So this guy was like checking his phone
and look at the bag check.
I mean like 30 seconds had gone by and
he goes,
I have a flight to catch,
excuse me,
I have a flight to catch.
And the woman who grabbed his back,
he said,
what are the odds?
You're at an airport and you got a
flight to catch how crazy.
And she goes,
hey,
you got a water bottle in your bag,
dummy.
And she pulled in.
Everybody was laughing.
It was funny because the guy was being a
con and the girl just kind of called
them out on it.
And the way she did it was very
humorous.
I got a good chuckle out of it.
Yeah,
that's good.
I mean,
yeah,
you see,
I always try to show it to your point
about showing some respect to the TSA
agents.
I have my confrontations
with them somewhat.
Do you,
what kind of conversations that you had?
Well,
just in the sense that like just a a
couple of weeks ago,
I guess it was when I came down to see
Dave,
I was with my girlfriend and they were
going through.
They were going through a bag.
They held my girlfriend's bag but they
were just holding it for like two point
four minutes.
We weren't in a rush,
but I'm like,
the guy wasn't even acknowledging that.
Like,
hey dude,
our stuff's here.
Like we're kind of just standing here
waiting.
And I'm like.
And I said to him like,
are you enjoying your little bit of
power right now?
Like,
I don't understand what,
what you're doing this to us.
We said please and thank you were doing
like doing our stuff.
So just these little confrontations.
I had a massive,
when I was in,
when I was installing highschool because
9:11 happened when I was in twelfth
grade and I flew down to uh,
uh,
in 2000,
two,
early 2002,
I flew down to Virginia to see my sister
who was teaching down there and um,
I,
they were going through my stuff,
my bags and stuff like that and I had a
confrontation with the TSA.
Were there,
some of them,
one of them was like,
son,
do you know what happened or whatever,
you know.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I know what happened.
I'm from New York,
I live in new,
heard of [inaudible] and my dad's in New
York City.
Firefighter.
Yeah,
I understand what happened,
you know,
and like to the point where like where
they called over,
like I was a 17 year old kid and they're
to the point where they called over like
some cops and then they just let me go
whatever.
But I was like,
at that point it was sold in me where
I'm like,
why are you being so why are you
disrespecting me?
Like you're going through my stuff.
If I'm a little upset about that or I
have something to say about that,
like I understand you have to probably
deal with this all day,
but don't,
don't because I'm a young kid.
I don't know what happened because I'm a
young man.
I,
you had no idea what my experience was.
Were you at the funeral for a
firefighter that you knew that died?
You know,
I was so like,
you know,
it's,
it's that kind of stuff always.
I think it's so to seed in me very early
with them.
Where am I?
So I,
I acknowledged that part of it too,
where it's like there is a little bit of
a chip on my shoulder with them.
I'm sure that is.
I never have a confrontation with them.
I'm always super friendly,
uh,
go through say hi to people.
I just,
I just treated it as like,
just,
this is what I'm doing now.
I don't say this is a big inconvenience.
I just say,
this is what you have to do.
This is what I'm doing now.
I do respect this idea that the fourth
amendment is being violated,
but I do not see a better alternative.
If I did,
I would think that what we should
definitely follow that protocol,
whatever the better alternative is.
I just think whenever you have non
skilled labor in those sorts of
situations,
like the guy working the fries at Burger
King or the guy who's,
you know,
doing that thing at the Tsa,
you're going to get a wide variety of
people that need a job.
Right?
And some of them are just going to suck
at protocol.
They're going to suck at being polite.
They're gonna suck it.
Recognizing that this old.
I don't think they have any leeway
either.
If some old lady comes through in a
wheelchair,
I'm pretty sure you have to check her
just like you check everybody else and
if you don't you'll probably get fired.
They have cameras and watching them
everywhere.
So it's not their fault.
The organization itself,
the Tsa,
I mean there's a diffusion of
responsibility when you're in one of the
people that's responsible,
you're at the top and you make these,
these laws and then you pass them down
to the people that are supposed to
enforce all these regulations that you,
you know,
you've,
you've written down.
There's almost like this is a diffusion
of responsibility from the people that
have created those.
They don't have to enforce them.
They're not.
They're doing it so
someone else,
it's someone else's job,
the $10 an hour guy,
it's his job to go out there and do all
this stuff and so it's real easy for
someone at the top who's not
experiencing the interaction,
the day to day interaction with these
human beings to be callous about it or
to make like hard,
fast rules like,
hey,
if someone comes through in a
wheelchair,
there's no leeway,
let them go.
But then again,
you have to think about it and their
point of view.
Like if someone was a terrorist and they
did decide,
well,
here's what we do.
I mean,
they've been proven for a fact.
They've used children as suicide
bombers,
so why wouldn't you use an old lady?
You know?
Why wouldn't you use an old man?
Why don't you use someone in a
wheelchair?
You certainly could.
So you have to follow the same protocol
with everybody.
Everybody that goes through has to be
scanned.
You can't let someone need not be
scanned just because they're old.
Like you've reached a certain amount of
years on this planet.
You wouldn't do anything fucking crazy
would you,
bob,
you know?
No,
not me.
You know,
you,
you can't think like that.
Because if you do think like that,
that will be your vulnerability.
That will be the path in that someone is
looking to do something horrible will,
will take.
I think that the.
I think the solution drove to bridge the
gap in the way we feel about this and
come to some sort of consensus what
might be in this conflict.
A little with my small government kind
of mentality,
but it's just to say like,
to ask the kind of fundamental question,
why are these people being paid 10 or
$15 an hour back to the Israeli
experience with these guys that are
professionals there.
They take a lot of pride in their work.
They make maybe 80,000,
$100,000 a year and they,
you know,
not that they necessarily need to make
that much money,
but people that are professional,
should we invest more money and making
the smarter,
you know,
it would be a substantial increase in
our airline fees and other things I'm
sure.
Sure.
Maybe it wouldn't.
Maybe going,
well we already pay a little bit of that
but with tickets,
but I think homeland security might be
able to.
Maybe we stopped dropping bombs on a
bunch of countries and take some of that
money and put it on and put it on,
you know,
into that area.
What else you suggest no more drones.
Fucking communists.
Who is this guy?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
the Israeli thing is interesting because
Israel has a mandatory military service
requirement that I am not in favor for
favor of,
but I am a part of me.
I feel,
I feel the benefit of it like you've,
it's very rare to meet people that are
more patriotic than Israelis,
you know,
people that are more,
uh,
more committed to their country.
It's like a very,
I mean,
they feel very marginalized,
very targeted and rightly so.
And so because of that,
like the people that I've met that work
for the Israeli army or that have been,
uh,
soldiers over there,
they have this very intense sort of a
view of altercation and of the world.
And when you're forced to do two years
of military service mandatory like they
are,
you also have,
you're invested in this whole project of
Israel.
I mean there's no,
there's no veterans and civilians.
Everyone's a fucking veteran and you
know,
when you deal with a country where it
literally everyone does some military
service.
There's everybody's,
there's more chips in the game,
you know,
people are all in different,
different scenario.
Yeah.
I think I went to school with this girl
that was Israeli when I was at
northeastern and Boston and uh,
I remember very clearly she had this
very unassuming you would never know,
but she had this picture of her with an
assault rifle shooting at a range.
And I'm like,
this is so,
so interesting.
It conflicts because I agree with you.
It's like one of those things where I'm
like,
I don't,
I can see both sides of this where um,
I don't know that the state should have
the right to exert that kind of power
over a person,
but at the same time does it have to be
military service?
And when a person turns 18,
is it fair to say like,
just spend a couple of years and give
something to your country and whether
it's you,
you,
you work in a soup kitchen or something
or you do something that is for the
society and really have some,
some investment in some skin in the game
in society.
I think that that's a nice idea,
but I think that the way I feel about
the state's exertion of power over the
individual kind of overrides that,
but I like,
I like the idea in principle,
like the idea of saying like,
hey,
and it's also easy for me is a 32 year
old.
That would be long,
you know,
it'd be like,
yeah,
you guys do it.
So at the same time,
I understand that argument as well.
No,
I think I'm completely in agreement with
you.
I love the idea that they're all in,
but I don't want anybody in forcing that
on me and I want.
I want a kid.
If a kid grows up in America and then
decides,
Hey man,
I'm going to backpack across the country
now.
You can't.
You got to join the army.
You fuck,
I don't want that.
You know,
I want.
I want people to be doing whatever the
fuck they want.
Hey,
I want to be a,
a fly fishing guide in Colorado.
No,
you can't.
You have to clean machine guns,
right?
No.
Fuck that.
I love the fact that America has so much
ultimate freedom for like what you
choose to do and not to do.
Look,
we live in this sort of a experiment in
self government and you can not
participate if you want to.
I liked that.
I'd like to.
You don't have to vote.
I mean,
I'm not saying that everybody should
fuck off and not vote,
but I am saying that I liked that it's
your option.
Me Too.
I think they have compulsory voting in
Australia,
I want to say,
and they'll tell that works out.
Fucking kangaroos everywhere.
Crocodiles,
spider is poisonous.
Bugs and shit.
Got The place.
Looks horrifying.
But the,
uh,
no,
I've never been either been.
I lived there.
That's number three on my list yet we're
number one.
America,
number two,
Canada,
number three,
Australia.
That seems like a pretty reasonable.
Let's,
I mean I could list just being in the
gaming industry.
I know a lot of people,
some people I really love that came from
Australia,
really friendly people,
but the interior,
that country sounds like a just an
absolute fucking shit show.
It's crazy,
but
it's also really gorgeous.
It's wild.
Uh,
I have a good buddy who lives over there
who goes into the interior all the time
and he,
uh,
he's the one who sent me a video of a
brown snake getting killed by some evil
spider.
There's some brown snake kills you
instantly and there's some evil spider
that was killing the brown snake.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Kind of a shit hole.
Do you live in Adam?
He's,
he's a madman.
He's out there living in that shit.
A man like me would not be able to
survive their camps out there.
He goes out into the Bush and shoots
buffalo's a bow and arrow.
He's and he's a maniac,
but the area of,
uh,
Australia is the size of the continental
United States,
but there's as many people as less than
the amount of people
that live in the greater Los Angeles
area live in the entire.
This whole fucking continent of
Australia.
It's nuts.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
It's like Perth on the,
on the west coast,
and then it's just the Sydney and
Melbourne,
right on the east coast.
And that's basically cleans Queensland,
Queensland.
There's a few other places,
but the bottom line is there's a giant
percentage of that place where you don't
want to get caught dead.
No,
no,
I,
I wouldn't.
I'm the kind of guy with like where I
see a spider and I have to argue with my
girlfriend who is going to kill it.
So I don't,
I don't want to.
I don't want to be really.
Yeah,
I hear you.
We step up.
It's always,
it's always,
it always ends up on me,
but I hate.
I hate,
I hate spiders.
So,
so if I see even these little,
I hate them.
Do you get a rack in a phobia?
Do you know?
I don't think I have that.
I'm not going to like,
if I see one calling me,
I'm not going to run out the house,
but I'm like,
oh,
I don't want to.
Is this thing in a job I have to like
really think about my strategy on how
I'm going to kill this thing.
It's one of those things where I'm like,
so if I was in Austria,
I'm just being honest with you.
So I was in Australia,
you know,
that'd be super careful in Australia.
Oh my God,
Dude.
I see some of these things when people
were outside barbecuing,
even in Melbourne or something like
that,
and the camera pans the.
It's a brown snake.
And I'm like,
holy Jesus,
God,
I wouldn't.
I don't know.
The waters are filled with sharks.
If you get past the sharks,
they're filled with jelly fish.
You get to the shore is poisonous
spiders.
You go into the hills.
Is Poisons fucking snake.
What is it about that part of the world?
They're like ruthless unbelieved.
Yeah,
they were the man of war and all that
kind of stuff in the water and,
and,
and the,
the box jellyfish or the scariest can
kill you.
They kill you if you fall into some sort
of a patch or what do they call them?
A school of Jellyfish.
If you accidentally stumble upon one,
you're a dead person.
You're fucked.
I mean,
they just,
you're dead instantly.
That's really crazy.
They're a little tiny guys,
right?
To someone that's warm on you in their
heart.
They're jellyfish are always scary
because growing up on long island we had
obviously harmless jellyfish,
but they would wash up on the shore
sometimes and I used to look at them.
I was kind of like,
well,
these are so strange.
What is this,
Jamie?
A spider.
Killing a brown snake.
Another one,
so spiders just eat ground snakes all
the time.
He's according that the weapons for cool
fine webs are awesome.
It's horrifying.
Not,
not to me.
Snakes or cons.
I don't know whose team I'm on.
I think I'm on team snake more than I am
on a team sport.
I think I am too,
just because they're less scary to me.
Plus,
well you can eat spiders.
Apparently tarantulas are delicious and
they cook them a lot.
In the Amazon they have these big
spiders that they cook and there are a
lot like crabs.
They taste like crabs and apparently
they're really similar in their lineage
or genetic.
Interesting.
Yeah,
I mean if you put a piece of.
If you put a spider and from it.
I didn't know what it was.
I'd be fine.
I know.
Even if I didn't know what it was,
if you know it's not gonna kill you when
it's dead.
So yeah,
if it's good,
if it's delectable,
that's why I shouldn't say I've eaten
spiders before on fear factor.
I have eaten a couple of spiders.
I eat a cave African cave dwelling.
Spider.
Jamie just freaked out.
You must have seen some things on that
show,
man.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm.
I'm pretty numb.
Yeah,
I guess that explains a lot of your kind
of more.
You've seen it all like an old
prostitute.
I've seen too much,
you know.
No 50 year
old prostitute in Holland.
Like whatever smoking a cigarette you
can show her do to me that lipstick on
my teeth.
I'm not even bothered to clean it off.
I'm,
I'm curious about,
because you brought it up before,
but what is your stance on Snowden?
Uh,
it seems like you're against the NSA and
all that kinda stuff,
but what is your stance on him?
Like I'm curious.
Like what do you think he should come
back?
Do you think that he is a patriot?
I think he's more of a Patriot than he
is a trader.
I agree,
but I think it's a very complex issue
when you give away national secrets and
your you have signed an oath that you're
not going to give away national secrets.
You sign an oath of secrecy and then you
give away national secrets,
but if those national secrets are in the
case of Edward Snowden,
they're very detrimental to what we
think of as freedom in this country.
Like if you have a bunch of people like
you or me or Jamie or it just a normal
person and they work at the NSA and they
can,
as he said,
he said,
spy on their ex girlfriend's read their
emails,
go into anybody's email that you want to
check,
check them out,
and then we were also being lied to by
the government about the extent of these
searches and he exposed that that the
president was saying it's just metadata
and he was saying,
no,
it's not just metadata.
It's not.
It's the actual emails is the actual
text messages.
See actual photos that you're sending to
each other.
They can get those.
They have all of those and that they're
storing all this stuff.
People were horrified,
but this is also something that was
exposed.
There was an NSA whistleblower from
boom,
I want to say 2011.
There was a guy who was a,
I think he was a coder and the NSA,
and he's gone public with this,
but he didn't go public with this in the
same way where he dumped a bunch of
documents and and let people go through
them like Edward Snowden did.
And he also didn't face the consequences
that Edward Snowden did as well.
He didn't really.
He was criticized and you know,
it was debated whether or not him
talking about it at all was legal or
whether it should be able to,
but ultimately he didn't face the same
kind of consequences.
Mean Edward Snowden can't live in
America anymore.
I mean,
Chelsea manning has been exonerated or
what would have been pardoned.
Pardon?
Yeah.
Is that the word wasn't a partner when
you did commuter to sentence commuted
the sentence.
Right.
So the commute the sentence,
and she's allowed to be free in May,
so in a couple months she'll be free,
but he's stuck in Russia and he
essentially the difference being,
they said that Chelsea manning went to
like went through the court system was
tried and then Obama decided that it was
a good enough amount of time and then he
was going to commute the sentence.
So I kind of see their point there that
Edward snowden fleed and didn't go
through the whole but.
But why wouldn't he flee?
You're going to lock them in a fucking
cage.
Chelsea manning was locked in a cage 24
hours a day with the lights on,
with no fucking clothes in solitary
confinement.
Confinement for,
I don't know how long,
but it was a long period of time.
I want to say years,
I want to say how long was find out?
How long was Chelsea manning in solitary
confinement for?
Because I know the way they did it,
it was cold in there and they took away
all her clothes or it was his clothes.
At the time was he,
was he.
And when did you.
When did you start saying him or her a
deal with that?
Yeah,
I don't.
I think at the All Africa point when
you're thinking back on the person
before they transitioned,
like do you say that Bruce Jenner won
the Olympics,
so do you say the Caitlyn Jenner won the
Olympics?
Jesus,
I don't know another way to say the
wrong thing.
Okay.
The former army analysts with two weeks
of solitary confinement connection with
the suicide attempt in July.
No,
no,
no.
That's just one.
The declined to discipline them with two
weeks now,
but she's been in solitary confinement,
not just over the suicide attempt.
This is.
This is like way late.
That's 2016 go.
I'm not.
Not the solitary confinement after
suicide attempt,
but just go to solitary confinement and
don't look at Chelsea,
look at Bradley manning solitary
confinement.
It was before he was tried.
Yeah,
it was like you could say he say he can
you get yelled at?
I bet you could.
I'm sure you will for say he,
but I think it's reasonable to say
before the transition when you went back
and posterity on on a person.
Maybe it's up to that person,
but I would assume that the Pronoun
would change at that point.
Give a fuck.
It's ridiculous.
Confusing.
It's so stupid.
There was a.
There was a case of A.
I'm a transgender fighter who was a man
for 30 years.
Became a woman for two years and started
beating the fuck out of these women and
didn't tell them by the way.
Oh,
so they didn't.
So the organizers or whatever it didn't.
He didn't tell us she whatever,
didn't tell the people that she was
fighting,
but here's the best part about it.
I was debating with someone online and
this woman said that she's always been a
woman,
that this person has always been a
woman.
And I said,
okay,
do you realize that this person fathered
a child?
I said,
so even when he was a man having sex
with a woman and got her pregnant,
he was a.
He was a woman then and this woman goes,
even then I'm like,
okay,
we're done.
We'll fuck.
That doesn't make sense.
I owe 23 hours a day for over an 11
month period.
Shit and conditions that he also found
might have constituted tortured,
tortured Juan Mendez has completed a 14
month investigation and the treatment of
manning since the soldiers arrested US
military base in May of 2010.
He concludes the US military was at
least culpable of cruel and inhumane
treatment and keeping manning locked up
alone for 23 hours a day for an over an
11 month period in conditions that he
found.
Okay.
So yeah,
that was,
that was what it was.
It was,
it was almost a year of solitary
confinement and I'm pretty sure that he,
at the time she now was naked and um,
they took everything away from him.
No books,
no nothing.
So it's really nothing to read.
Nothing cold.
They keep it cold to keep it cold where
you're like barely able to tolerate it.
Holy Shit.
What do you do?
Like what is your,
what is your,
what are the places your mind goes?
I would start doing Kung Fu.
Yeah.
I'll just start.
Just start working on it.
I'd be like Wesley Snipes in that one
movie where they kept him locked up,
I think stripped naked at night.
Yeah.
I think that,
you know,
what,
what they did was what they are allowed
to do.
You know,
you're allowed to do whatever you want
to do when you get someone locked up
like that.
They don't really have the kind of
rights that are around an average person
does.
You get locked up for treason and there
was a tremendous amount of heat coming
towards the US military when that wiki
leaks video.
Um,
uh,
what was the,
what was it called?
What did they call it?
Something about collateral murder.
I think that was what they call it.
Was it?
Was it,
was it drones or was it.
No,
it was a helicopter.
Oh,
I know.
Okay.
I know you talked about.
Yep.
Helicopter shooting.
Fucking horrific gunfire down on these
people.
That turned out to be reporters.
And then the callous attitude that these
soldiers showed in the video,
we can hear them talking about whether
or not there are kids in the van.
Well,
they shouldn't have brought kids.
Like the whole thing was like really
dark and I think in a lot of ways
exposure to that stuff is good because
unchecked behavior is extremely
dangerous.
That seemed like it was unchecked and it
seemed like unchecked behavior in a time
of war is extremely dangerous and it was
pretty obvious that when you looked at
what at Edward Snowden had revealed,
it was pretty obvious that the majority
of the American people had a huge
problem with it.
The majority of the American people,
you or I who are doing nothing wrong.
I'm not committing any crimes.
I'm not.
I'm certainly not victimizing anybody.
Why do they have access to my email?
Why?
There's no reason,
no reason.
You just can like that.
That seems insane and that to me is a
way clear violation of the fourth
amendment.
Then this weird sort of gray area.
Not necessarily great if you're looking
at it from a constitutional sense of how
they're allowed to check you out.
Yeah.
No,
that's great.
That's a very valid and solid argument.
I think because my,
my stance on manning specifically as
soften,
soften overtime because I feel like,
um,
you know,
when he or she can we call her Z,
Z.
I'm not trying to be disrespectful.
I just don't know.
What else was he in?
Disrespectful.
You fucking son of a bitch.
Sorry.
Racist too.
I know,
I know.
That's what that Lexis nexis will call
me a racist for the rest of my life.
Um,
but uh,
yeah.
To me it was like,
I felt like it was,
it was very.
They didn't take the time to,
to people died because of that stuff
like there,
there are people that were put in danger
because of the things that they were put
out because it wasn't,
they didn't carefully comb through it
and make sure that he's actually done.
Yeah.
I mean you could look,
I don't think that they look that,
look that up and say it's because of the
way wikileaks released it yet because I
don't think that.
I don't know if they're going to point
that specific things,
but the,
the way things were out there,
like I don't think all of the names were
blacked out.
I don't think like the operate the
operations and process,
like people were in play,
you know,
that we're being out at in that way.
I think the reason I was a little softer
on snowden was because not only was it
domestic primarily,
but which I think is an important
qualifier,
but also because I think he went out of
his way to not single any individuals
out.
It was all about the apparatus itself.
It wasn't about like saying like General
Blah Blah,
blah is doing this general or admiral,
but it was about like,
Hey,
this structure exists and it's really as
quite nefarious indeed.
You know?
And I think that.
So I was always to me my stance on him
as he's a patriot and you should be
welcomed home and the fact that he
wasn't.
He can't be,
I guess party hasn't been tried or
whatever.
But the fact that I know that some
people think that Obama only pardoned
manning because it made him look good
with the transgender community and with
the Lbgtq community,
which I think is a little.
There might be a living office though.
Well,
because it's part of his legacy.
Like it's part of what I'm saying.
Like,
you know,
it's the same reason why you know,
how much Ford was hurt when he pardoned
Nixon that stuck with them forever and a
negative way.
Well,
this is going to stick with Obama,
I think positively in a good way of
moving forward.
But I don't know that I'm,
I'm not,
I'm quite that callous and thinking that
that's the only reason.
I think that he probably had time to
marinate on it.
Clearly she went through some rigorous.
Well,
also what's important to point out is
that Obama's website,
the hope and change website that he had
when he was running for president and
when he got into office,
the original website had in it,
these provisions for how he was going to
treat whistleblowers with,
with,
uh,
they were gonna allow people to release
information that showed crimes and they
were going to protect them.
They're going to protect whistleblowers.
It was a very specific statement,
was a very specific approach that they
were having while he was running for
president about whistleblowers because
he was about exposing these agregious
offenses and when,
once he got into office,
one of the things that happened after
the Chelsea manning thing and after the
Edward Snowden things,
they removed that from the hope and
change website.
The removed that provision about
whistleblowers.
Interesting.
Because it's obviously,
it was obviously it was,
he was unable.
He's either a hypocrite or is unable to
keep that promise.
Right.
Well,
that goes back to the whole thing with
snowden.
When you're saying,
well you kind of take an oath to protect
these secrets and all that kind of
stuff,
but I look at it,
you know,
I don't want people to be flippant with
that kind of stuff that you were saying.
I want people to be flippantly being
like,
well this is,
I have some sort of personal problem
with this,
but I actually think it takes a level of
courage to be like,
what in the fuck is going on here?
Oh,
for sure.
And also I believe that before he gave
that information to Glenn Greenwald,
I believe he offered it to a bunch of
different mainstream news sources like
New York Times,
Washington Post.
I've correct me if I'm wrong,
Jamie.
I think that was in the documentary,
the,
the um,
I didn't see it or something like that.
You fell asleep,
tried to watch it in a hotel room.
What's up?
Just say which one do you want me to
look up because I got the.
It's a no,
no one died as a result of which one?
Which one?
The one earlier about Chelsea manning.
Jamie does it.
It doesn't say anything about that was,
I remember that being contentious that
they,
they were saying the reason that they
were upset about it was because they
were like,
this puts people that are in play in
danger.
Now.
Maybe that maybe that may be dangerous,
but maybe no one actually does good.
The writer had a,
a usa today piece,
I think about it and she got a lot of
heat for pope,
for even writing that up in the first
place.
That puts people in danger that people
died from the result of his leaks.
Okay.
So she got a lot of heat because they
haven't.
Oh,
interest is probably what it is.
You probably read that.
Okay.
Yeah man.
People again,
you're a racist and
people have died.
I mean Google says it but,
but you know what I'm saying?
I mean like,
people need clickbait.
So with her writing an article saying
that bunch of people died or someone
died.
It's this kind of the same thing.
They're trying to make something jucier
sure.
I'd go and even with the London
terrorist attack,
uh,
you know,
recent one.
Yeah.
The one that just happened where people
they've seen too,
I've identified the person,
get new sources that were that what you
think are reputable,
say it and then they have to retract it
later.
Everyone's.
Everyone's very quick to try to pull the
pull the gun first and be like,
well,
we have.
We have the story.
Yeah,
we're all victimized.
As you know,
people that are just,
you know,
we're not in the trenches,
so we need the information.
We have to trust these people and trust
is broken.
I think in a Lola and I certainly think
there should be some sort of a national
debate on whether or not Edward Snowden
is a hero.
You know,
whether or not Edward Snowden did
something that benefited the American
people because I certainly think the
overall reaction,
the overall,
like if you look at what Edward Snowden
did and then you look at what are the
consequences of what he did.
I think it's good for us because we got
to see that all these Alex Jones type
conspiracies were actually true when
Alex Jones is ranting and raving about
the government living in your emails.
One of the great episodes of the show,
by the way,
I love it,
but people were looking into that like
there's no fucking way.
There's no way that government really
looks into your email.
There's no way it doesn't happen,
but yes they do.
Like that was.
That was a stunner to me and this for me
was I'd been telling people that Alex
Jones,
who's my friend and has been my friend
for a long time and I get criticized so
much by people that they're like,
he's so crazy and he's such a fucking
right wing Wacko.
I'm like,
Alex Jones is not right wing.
He's not.
He's antigovernment.
He's anti tyranny and,
and he might be crazy as fuck and he
probably is,
but he's right about a lot of shit and
that's where it gets really scary.
So he's.
He was talking about the NSA,
looking into people's emails and having
the ability to,
like I found out about that NSA
whistleblower,
the original one.
See if you could find who that guy is.
I want to say yes,
yes.
Pull it,
pull it,
pull up that article.
I found out about that from Alex.
he told me about it.
I'm like,
what?
And then I hear Bill Binney,
the original NSA whistleblower on in
nine slash 11 and illegal surveillance.
Now.
He was a god,
I want to say it was before nine slash
11,
wasn't it?
Before nine slash 11.
Then he came out with this scroll down.
Oh,
was it right after nine slash 11.
He believes that nine slash 11 was
preventable.
A month after it happened.
He resigned in protest from the National
Security Agency bidding was part of an
elite NSA team that was,
which,
uh,
designed and built an intelligence
gathering system to target and collect
data on terrorism threats.
He belongs to an intimate group of,
of,
for whistleblowers,
each of whom left the NSA after raising
concerns about failures and the
agencies.
Intelligence gathering capabilities.
Yeah.
So he's a.
He was the first guy that was saying
what they're doing is bullshit.
And he alleges the NSA buried key
intelligence that could have prevented
nine slash 11.
He alleges the agency's bulk data
collection from Internet and telephone
communications is unconstitutional and
illegal in the U.
s he alleges that the NSA is ineffective
at preventing terrorism because analysts
are too swamped with information on.
That makes sense.
I'm under its bulk collection program.
That totally makes sense.
Yeah.
When you're.
When you have everything,
what do you.
Where do you begin?
Yeah,
I mean all those things that he's.
I mean,
that's.
There's no way.
I mean that's the thing.
Like a friend of mine,
I was joking around about this because
managers,
I'm just not comfortable with the NSA
reading my email.
I go,
of course you're not comfortable.
I'm not either.
But guess what,
who's fucking reading your shit man?
Nobody's reading your shit.
No,
that's not even the point.
Right?
Well,
it goes back to the point you were
making because with the Patriot Act
after 9:11,
they made the same argument.
Well,
if you have nothing to hide,
right.
But the problem is,
is soon as something comes up,
like they go,
hmm,
this column,
Moriarty,
he's been talking to a lot of shit.
Let's find out what he's into,
but I'll look at that.
A bunch of Dick Pics,
right?
Right.
Time to put those all in one that.
Hey Bro,
nothing wrong.
We take pictures.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah,
no,
I,
I think I kind of,
I think we're in the lead with that.
I think snowden is a hero.
Uh,
I,
I feel like what he did took a lot of
courage.
Uh,
and,
and it blow up his life.
I would like to,
if I go to Russia and uh,
I might go to Russia for the UFC.
I'd like to meet that dude.
I'll let you interview him.
He probably would talk to you.
Jamie,
you want to go to Russia?
Big Pause.
We'll talk about data when I was younger
and I was trying to think of like,
I don't want to put an next by him.
I don't want to put you on the spot,
but if it was possible to meet that guy,
I would love to meet that guy.
I don't know if they just let you meet
them though.
I bet it would be like really hard.
I know John Oliver met him.
Shane Smith did too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
Maybe I'd go with Shane.
Shane Hook it up.
You would probably love to talk to you.
I mean he,
he,
he seems like an interesting.
He's probably caught on a contract,
constant surveillance you have to
assume,
but I'm sure I would be fucked when I
came back.
They probably check everything.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I would like to sit down with that guy
for a few hours,
like a do like a six hour interview with
him and just pick them apart and ask
like,
what is your life like now man?
Like how many brushing chicks you
banging your here over here pay you.
What do you,
how do you eat?
What do you do to feed yourself?
Like where's he getting these money?
He must got a stipend of some sort.
You have to assume,
right?
I mean you have to.
I mean he's a guest of there so you have
to assume that he's taken care of in
some way.
Right.
But I mean he probably has to keep his
value high,
like at a certain point in time,
like they,
they,
they could say hey,
you're not valuable to us anymore time
to live in Guatemala,
bitch.
He,
I mean,
he's a very smart man,
so he must know at the highest level
that he is a geopolitical pawn that,
like you said,
could be played in any way at any point.
You know,
it was him.
I would just be listening to Rosetta
stone with Russia all day long.
I'll be like,
I need to find out how to speak Russian
and I need to fucking go hide in Siberia
or something and to grow my beard out.
Yeah.
He's,
he's an interesting cat.
Like I,
I,
I'm,
I'm somewhat fascinated by him.
I don't think we've,
I think you'll come back at some point
that Neil degrasse Tyson had a
fascinating interview with him on
startalk radio where I was in Neil
degrasse Tyson.
Essentially we're the same thing that he
thinks he's a patriot,
you know,
uh,
Neil doesn't really take too many
stances like that are really political
in that regard.
But I think as far as like data
collection or random of just a blanket
data collection of all the people in the
United States,
I think it's fucked.
And it's absolutely not what we think of
when we think of the freedom that the
United States supposedly provides its
citizens.
It seems like we're all under suspicion
then we're all being under surveillance.
That's some really creepy orwell type
shit,
you know,
that's just not what we want.
It's extremely Orwellian.
And I,
it goes,
I feel like with Snowden,
sometimes people miss the forest for the
trees with it.
They're very focused on the man in the
act,
but they're not focused on,
you know,
one of the things that I'm really
interested in is like,
what is the complicity?
Well,
what is the level of complicity with the
telecoms?
Like what is the complicity with the
government like forcing these people
and,
and there's a whole and how many
thousands of people are in on this?
And that's the whole,
that's the crazy thing is that snowden,
who was a contractor,
not even really in the inner sanctum of
the NSA,
knew all of this stuff.
There are people running around
thousands of people just acting like
this never happened or wasn't going on.
So it's a pretty,
it's not a conspiracy because we know
it's true,
but it's a pretty big thing where I'm
like focusing on Snowden is missing the
entire point.
There's like,
why are all like why didn't no one like
no sprint or t mobile?
Anyone was like,
Hey,
well you imagine the kind of cool would
have been for one of those companies
would be like we're not doing this.
And in fact like we're going to tell
everyone,
you know,
like,
what will this will make us look
amazing,
you know,
from a very shrewd corporate stance and
be like,
well we don't grow.
Let's be honest.
I would never happen.
And if it did happen they would come
down on that company so hard.
There has to be some weird sort of
arrangements of these gigantic
telecommunication companies like verizon
or something has with the federal
government and we just has to be.
I think it's just protecting the bottom.
I mean I'm sure that there's something
they can do,
but they don't care about anything but
money.
So I have a friend who used to be a big
executive at Google and she described to
me some of the conversations that they
had when they were dealing with the
government and search engines and being
able to access people's search engine
results.
And then also with China,
like how when Google went over to China,
like there was very specific things they
had to agree to what the government in
order to make sure that they were there,
they had to restrict the searches.
They had to.
They had to censor things.
I mean the government of China does not
feel the same way about freedom as the
government.
The United States and the government of
the United States gets real sketchy with
it.
W,
as soon as you're doing what Edward
Snowden has proven that they're doing,
you're getting really sketchy with
freedom.
I mean you can land of the free home of
the brave.
Except I want to look at your Dick Pics,
except I want to read your emails to
one,
to listen to your voicemails,
except I want to be able to track your
calls.
I accept.
I want to be able to know where your
phone is at all times.
I mean,
that metadata from where the location of
your phone is,
is one of the primary ways they target
terrorists.
I mean,
the people who are not aware of why so
many civilians die and these terrorist
attacks,
the part of the reason,
especially in the early days of drone
attacks,
um,
uh,
when they were trying to target
terrorists rather would,
was that they would use the metadata.
They would find out where the phones
are.
So if your phone was in this apartment
building,
they're going to bomb that apartment
building.
It's like,
whoa.
Yeah,
it's,
it's very deep.
It's very technical and I have no
problem with them going to a shadow
court and,
and getting like a permission to be
like,
we're tracking this guy's full right
now.
We're,
we're reading this guy or this
organization's emails or people that are
kind of within seven degrees of
separation or whatever from this person
there.
At least there's some sort of orderly
nature to it.
Right?
Like,
you don't need to be reading my emails
or my,
My,
you know,
I'm just getting uber receipt,
sent them an email where it's like,
what,
why are you even storing all this?
And I'm like,
what is,
what use is it other than the,
obviously they want friends,
they want data that they can big high
updata a eagle eye data and saying like
this is the trend and all these kinds of
things.
But it's all elba gotten because it's
like it's not it,
it's not right.
And that was the disappointing them and
you probably feel the same way.
Joe is like after snowden and the NSA
was a big store,
but then everyone kind of just like,
oh yeah.
And everyone kind of forgot,
well they're still kind of doing a lot
of the same kind of thing.
We didn't,
they didn't affect the way we know about
it now,
but we didn't.
We don't know that the level of change
that was affected really.
And,
and,
and to me,
I feel like this is the thing where you
got to keep the pedal down and you've
got to keep going and be like,
this is not okay,
this is not right.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
it's the same thing with um,
w with the Patriot Act back in the day
where everyone was really upset about
that.
We have every right to be upset about.
That's really egregious stuff.
Sure.
A mean,
the NDA,
what they've essentially done is they've
eliminated the right of due process.
They can lock you up for as long as they
want.
They can deny you any sort of a legal
representation.
That's,
that's,
that's all been taken away from us.
Now.
What used to be one of the foundations
of being an American,
the right to due process,
right to have a lawyer,
the right to a trial of your own peers.
All that stuff has kind of gone.
Now.
They just decide that you're a terrorist
and they could decide you're a terrorist
if you spell,
if you,
if you have weed on you,
if you are involved in illegal drugs,
you can be under the Patriot Act,
considered a terrorist.
It's really kind of crazy.
It is,
and it's.
It's scary in the sense too because it
goes back to what they were saying or
what this gentleman was saying that we
were just talking about where he was
saying like,
oh,
they have too much data.
They have too much to work with.
At some point someone has to be like,
Hey,
the guy with an ounce of weed or the guy
what you know,
even with four ounces of weed,
why are we dumping him in with all this
stuff that's just going to muddy the
waters more about the real target that
we're really going after,
which is someone that's actually going
to hurt someone or someone that's
actually going to cause a terrorist
incident.
To me,
I would,
if I were them,
I'd be like,
we need less.
We need way more targeted data.
We need to leave 325 million people
alone,
probably
pay the least,
and here's another big part of the
problem was that when Obama was
instituting these changes and when the
NDA got passed and when people were
saying,
well,
hey,
we're never going to use it.
This is one of the things that they
said,
we're never going to hold people without
legal representation,
and definitely they were going to use
the indefinite detainment.
Okay,
but that's you.
What if a crazy person becomes president
cut to president trump,
we now have a crazy person,
crazy person who's now president,
and you're like,
well,
now what?
Well,
what about these fucking crazy laws,
Obama that you pass when he thought that
it would be nothing but your standard
politicians and hopefully Democrats from
now to the end of time.
Guess what?
Now it's not now it's a guy who wants to
dismantle the environmental protection
agency.
Now it's a guy wants to drill pipelines
through.
The Dakota access is a guy that wants to
do a lot of stuff that people find to be
troubling and this guy has the same
rights to use.
The Nda as you did and he's the new guy
and he's kinda crazy.
Yeah.
And,
and that,
this is the level of restraint that
needs to be shown by someone in that
position because
he hasn't done anything yet.
I mean,
you can't say he has used it,
but he's only been an officer a couple
months.
Yeah.
Given time.
Uh,
but to me it's like it goes back to the
argument of a,
of a executive orders.
It goes back to the argument of all of
these things were,
or the filibuster in the Senate,
uh,
where what's good for the goose is good
for the gander.
You can't set up these,
these rules that are just going to
backfire on you and then complain about
them later.
To me,
I think it's a huge mistake.
That's why I have a lot of respect for
presidents.
We haven't had one in a long time that
there are more restrained.
The presidents at that differ executive
power and actually say like maybe the
legislature should be dealing with these
kinds of things.
We need a man like that or someone like
that.
Who's ever done that?
Oh,
I mean,
back in the,
I mean it's been a lot of time,
the gilded age of coolidge and heart and
those guys,
but ever since FDR really the imperial
presidency grew in power and all these
kinds of things.
And before you knew it,
you had a little canaries in the coal
mine with like,
I was actually talking to dave about it
last night with Eisenhower with the
military industrial complex and all
these kinds of amazing,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
like an amazing,
really.
I don't think people realize how insane
that is that,
that man said that will explain what he
said and when he said it.
So,
uh,
Eisenhower was president from a 52 to
60,
so we'll typically 50,
30,
61.
And uh,
he was obviously one of the instrumental
generals in the allied assaults on Japan
and on,
on Nazi Germany.
And he saw the influence of the military
growing and that in the Cold War and the
Nixon era of the Cold War,
that we were making bombs to make bombs
that we were trying to have conflicts
with Korea.
Which you tried that.
What she did end in the early fifties,
and so seeing that,
seeing these seeds sown that of
perpetual war of perpetual war,
that the economy was actually benefiting
from Jamie,
pull up that speed
because it's an amazing speech.
It would be nice for people to hear it
has a lot of people are not aware of the
tone and the way set it and it was when
he was leaving off.
Sorry if I'm not doing a good job of.
No,
no,
no.
You did a great job.
Okay.
And so and so.
He's a man of a military background.
Everyone loved Eisenhower like because
of what he did in the war and he a two
term President Nixon was very popular,
but at the end he was like,
you gotta watch what's going on over
here.
I'm telling you,
yes,
you can trust me.
I'm from that world and watch what's
happening.
It's a speech.
Play a Jamie,
cool speech.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the president of the United States.
Good evening,
my fellow Americans.
We now stand 10 years past the midpoint
of a century that has witnessed for
major wars among great nation
until the latest of our world conflicts.
The United States had no armaments
industry,
American makers of ploughshares could
with time and that required make swords
as well,
but we can no longer risky emergency
improvisation of national defense.
We have been compelled to create a
Permanent Armand is industry of bash
proportion.
I to do this.
Three and a half million men and women
are directly engaged in the defense.
Establish now this conjunction of an
immense military establishment and a
large arms industry is new in the
American experience,
but total influence,
economic,
political,
even spiritual is felt in every city,
every state house,
every office of the federal government.
We recognize the imperative need for
this development,
yet we must not fail to comprehend it's
grave.
Implications are toil,
resources,
and livelihood are all involved.
So is the very structure of our society
and the councils of government.
We must guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence,
whether sought or unsought by the
military industrial complex.
The potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist.
We must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
democratic processes.
We should take nothing for granted.
Only an alert and knowledgeable citizen
can compel the proper meshing of the
huge industrial and military machinery
of defense with our peaceful methods and
goals so that security and liberty may
prosper together.
Jesus.
It's an amazing.
At the time that was an amazing speech
and it's just prescient like it's
because people don't understand and you
know,
like before World War II,
you know,
we weren't a built up under a
militarized society.
We would militarize when we need it to
and,
and it was really Teddy Roosevelt and
all those kinds of guys that started to
kind of get a little more bullish and
that kind of regard with the Spanish
American war and,
and the USS Maine and,
and that,
you know,
but the fight over world war one was
real.
You know,
we didn't want to get involved.
We got involved very late and people
take for granted.
Now that we have just massive military
and we have this massive power,
but then in the 19th century that not
that they're,
you know,
you can't equate them necessarily to the
21st century.
We didn't,
we weren't going around running rough
shot over people and like doing those
kinds of things.
We were very isolationist.
That was kind of the American tradition
and to hear that come out of
Eisenhower's mouth,
especially knowing his experiences in
the war and his and his deep knowledge
of the military and what was going on in
the world.
So it's one of the great warnings of all
time in American history
and it's very wise in his part because
he recognized that there is survival
systems that are a part of any industry.
You know,
it's a,
there's survival mechanisms that the
industry wants to stay alive.
If all of a sudden there's peace on
earth.
This gigantic industry,
this multiple billion dollar a year
industry.
I mean,
I don't know how much.
It's trillions a year,
right?
What is the,
what's the military budget?
Pretty $600,000,000,000 a year.
$600,
million dollars of new spending.
So you know,
you have trillions of dollars worth of
equipment,
Jesus Christ,
so that massive amount of money,
um,
there's so many people that are involved
in that and so many jobs that have to be
preserved and so much of the industry
relies on keeping conflict,
active,
uh,
active.
And I think that's what he was trying to
warn us about,
but it's so interesting about it and
evolve citizenry and that people need to
be aware of it.
And to hear that from the president,
you're never going to hear anything
remotely as even close to his candidate
is that is today?
No,
absolutely not.
And I think that even hearing that from
a,
you know,
just to reiterate like hearing that from
Barack Obama for instance,
would be strong,
right?
But hearing that from a ulysses s grant
or Zachary Taylor or a guy that served
especially the level he served as like
that,
that meant something to people and it,
and,
and I think that that's why that saying
never went away,
but,
but under our noses it happened and what
he said was going to happen is exactly
what happened in the Southeast Asia,
in Vietnam,
Cambodia,
Laos,
he,
he called it from a fucking mile away.
Well,
it wasn't even a mile away because he
was living there.
I mean,
he was in the heat of it in 1960 when he
made that speech.
You think about the Gulf of Tonkin
incident.
I mean that's just a few years later,
still few years later,
they had a false flag that allowed
people to get enthusiastic about
entering into the Vietnam War.
And that's where it all came from.
Right.
And it's the same,
you know,
some people say the USS Maine and
Spanish American war in 18,
98 was another false flag or something
that was,
they let happen or something that was
blown out of proportion,
you know,
pardon the pun,
because it was about shit blowing up.
But yeah,
it's one of those,
it is a provocation that gets everyone
involved.
And they had,
we had this nemesis.
It was good versus evil.
We were upset when we saw,
I think especially against the Nazis,
we saw what the stature of the good
versus evil argument and we won.
So with the allies.
So we,
I think we tried to perpetuate that
immediately.
The Soviets became the evil and then we
created our bombs and then they created
their bombs and then we just had this,
these proxy wars that we were fighting
against the Chinese and Korea.
And then the Soviets in Vietnam really
like all these things that were kind of,
you know,
everyone knew what was going on.
But no,
I'm sorry.
No,
please go on.
Just you.
I was just gonna say.
So I think that when the Soviet,
when everything started to get peaceful,
I wonder,
they call it glasnost and Soviet,
Soviet,
which is like the idea of a new era like
peace and prosperity with the West or
whatever in like the late seventies,
early eighties,
I think that the,
the,
the Boeings of the world and the,
and the Halliburtons of the world were
like,
Oh shit,
you know,
and,
uh,
become nineties,
but we immediately found new targets and
we should be wary of why that happened.
You know,
I'm not saying that we shouldn't
necessarily fight,
we have to fight sometimes,
but to have this industrialized nature
of it,
to have this need to lurch from one war
to the next quarter,
the next quarter,
the next war is not what a,
a thriving republic does.
It's what a dying empire does.
Well,
it's definitely
what an empire that's dependent upon the
control or the or rather an industry
rather than.
It's dependent upon the control that it
has currently maintaining it.
You need to maintain that,
that money.
You need to maintain the business.
The business of making these machines
and of having these contracts,
I mean it's a huge industry and like all
of these unlimited growth industries,
it's very like every business
essentially operates under this paradigm
of unlimited growth or most businesses
do.
Most corporations do where they kind of
every year they want to make more money
and if that's applicable to accompany
that makes tanks well every year they
want to make more money.
They want to make more tanks.
We don't need tanks anymore.
Well how the fuck you don't.
You definitely need to.
Oh look what's going on over here in
Yemen.
Real Shit.
You need some tanks,
right?
Exactly.
And that's means team America,
world police.
It's,
it's really crazy.
It's scary and it's a scary waste of
money too because I don't think that we.
I really do feel like we should have the
most powerful military in the world.
I don't think that there's anything
wrong with that.
I think you're right.
I think a powerful Republican have those
kinds of things,
but we don't need all of these bases
that are legacy basis.
Why are we still in Japan?
Why are we still in place?
They talk some shit and or Godzilla
shows up.
Trump's proposed height to military
spending is bigger than all but two
countries.
Entire budgets.
Well that's because we're America and
we're better than everybody else.
Yeah,
I want to say it.
That communists shit off my screen.
I want to say,
I mean this is incredible.
I want to say I think this is right that
if you split the military spending of
the world in thirds,
we've.
We are responsible for a third of it.
10 countries are responsible for another
third of it and then everyone else is
responsible for another third of it.
We have four and a half percent of the
world's population,
so this is way out of whack when with
with even our needs,
like our actual very need to protect
ourselves.
I think it's just way out of whack.
Right?
But when you get past those 10 countries
that there are other third and then us,
that's 11 countries.
Everybody else is using coconuts and
catapults.
That's essentially throwing rocks at
each other.
So.
But there's relative tranquility,
like outside of the Middle East and in
East Eastern Europe with the Ukraine and
Russia,
there's general peace to be had in,
in these countries that might not spend
a lot of money or might not even have a
lot of money to spend them on saying I
want to live like they do with that I
want,
I don't want to spend,
say I want to live like they do in Sri
Lanka,
Bangladesh or something like that.
But I'm saying like,
man,
you racist.
That's already been established by the
International Business Times.
Uh,
but to me,
I just look at it.
I'm like,
we can spend this money wiser and we can
have,
we can,
we can ramp up and have plans to ramp up
people forget.
And you know,
Gm Ford,
all these guys were making our
armaments.
You know,
Mitsubishi made the Japanese Zeroes,
IBM offshoots of IBM.
We're making frigging punch card
machines for the Nazis.
You know,
like people,
people,
you know,
for better or for worse,
ramp up and do what they need to do in
times of war to make money.
And so we could have a plan in place to
say like,
Hey,
if we need to ramp up,
it's something bad happens if we need to
go overseas or something,
if we have to go engage the Russians
because they're rolling into the rest of
Ukraine for instance,
we have the uh,
the we can,
we can take care of that without having
bases all over the world.
Well,
the problem with that kind of thinking
is as soon as you say that,
then they realize,
wow,
there's a lot of money to be had if that
is the case.
So let's make that the case.
And then there's some weird fucking
covert sneaky shit going down.
And do you have an earring on both ears?
They,
the other headphones.
Irritating.
You don't know.
I just like to hear whenever I did I do
this.
Not all the hearings had been in since I
was like 18.
I just took them out.
I'm superstitious.
So you're superstitious.
Yeah.
So I don't like to,
you know,
not like over overtly superstitious,
but I'm afraid to take them out.
I'm afraid to do different things.
You have a,
we the people tattoo on your arm?
Yeah,
we,
the people and then I have franklins
association snake on here.
So you're like join or die.
Wow.
So you're like a serious,
almost like a fan of politics that way
to describe it.
Sure.
I meant when I went to college,
I went to school for American history
and I graduated and when I got my job
offer in the video game industry,
I was about to start my graduate degree
at northeastern in American history
because I want it to be a professor at
the time.
So my real passion was American history
in American politics,
but I veered off into a different
direction.
No,
please go ahead.
I was just saying,
so these are like relics,
so I got these when I was like 20,
you know.
Wow,
that's interesting man.
That's a,
those are unusual tattoos for 20 year
old.
Yeah.
I,
I just,
you know,
I,
I love,
uh,
I'm really interested in the founding
generation.
I'm really interested in,
in their experiences.
And the American revolution I think is a
fascinating revolution compared to a lot
of other revolutions.
Primarily because it is,
I think it inherently in some ways,
conservative revolution,
which is not common.
These were incredibly rich people
fighting.
These weren't like poor destitute
people.
John Hancock had something like 350th of
all of the value of the colonies under
is under his name.
People had everything,
the risk and everything to lose,
so it's like an interesting,
I think,
very principled revolution that they
fought.
Although if you read like Howard Zinn or
something that they would say that they
did it to protect their money,
but I'm sure they did,
but I'm sure they had other motives as
well.
Of course,
and it's a.
it's a sort of an unprecedented thing in
human history.
I mean it's a really crazy union that
we've established over here to see all
of these things that threaten what we
find so amazing about it.
Like the violations of the fourth
amendment,
all the NSA stuff with Edward Snowden,
all these different things that we see
that that are huge problems.
What they are is also they're.
They're weakening the foundation of
these ideas that were so amazing when
they were first established in 17,
76 and,
and uh,
to me that's why I think that they're
worth protecting and it goes to,
it goes into the like is the
constitution living or not?
Is it,
is a strict constructionist or loose
constructionists.
All those kinds of questions I think are
valid,
but to me I'm like,
we can't,
we have this very unique vision into
what the founders intended because they
were one of the few,
I think people,
people at that time that were like,
we're going to,
you know,
the federalist papers are incredible if
you read them,
like we don't have to wonder what they
meant.
They literally tell you exactly what
they meant.
So when you go to supreme court cases,
I don't know that there are many supreme
court cases that don't even reference
the federalist papers because it's like,
well they said this an article three,
section two,
but actually in this paper that they
wrote anonymously that we know Alexander
Hamilton wrote,
here's what he said about it.
You know.
And I think that's interesting stuff.
Now,
how did this knowledge of politics and
how this fascination that you have with
the history of the United States,
how did this get you in,
you know,
quote unquote trouble in the video game
industry with these people that are
predominantly left wing and
predominantly progressive?
Like quota?
I say progressive,
but progressive is kind of a dirty word
now,
but it's coming.
There's a difference between liberal and
progressive.
Well,
it would be great if everybody was
liberal.
If it would be great if everybody was
progressive and it'd be great if
everybody wanted people to have freedom
of choice and freedom to be whoever you
want,
but that's not really what those things
are anymore.
Those things are like ideologies.
There are these predetermined patterns
of behavior that people subscribe to in
a very,
very rigid way.
How,
what did you find was an issue when
people found out about your extreme
understanding and a respect for the
history of the United States?
Well,
they think it's a.
primarily they think it was kind of a
joke because not not,
not a hot hydro,
but like you're,
you're a clown kind of.
Because why?
Because I believe in small government,
for instance,
I believe in low taxation,
I believe in the elimination of the
income tax and things like this.
These are,
these are Rad,
but I don't actually have like,
not all my ideas are radical or even
outside of the mainstream.
Socially.
I'm probably further to the left that
many of these people,
you know,
uh,
I think that it goes back to this idea,
and this is something Dave Rubin has
touched on a lot in this show,
which I'm sure you're familiar with,
which is this idea that it's really all
or nothing,
like they don't want to be an ally with
someone that might be able to help them
in x,
Y,
and Z if they disagree with people in a,
B and c.
So they could have had a great ally in
me and being like,
I've been pro gay marriage forever.
I've been pro choice.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
um,
for the decriminalization of drugs,
I'm for the legalization of
prostitution.
I'm for a lot of these things that are
very far to the left socially that we
probably could find some agreement on
somewhere.
And we can work on those things and get
those things done together.
But because I say also like,
Hey,
the income tax is predatory and really
hurts people.
I own a business.
I owned a business and I went,
I guess I want another one now.
And I know that I could have hired
another person if taxes weren't so
onerous on me.
Um,
and so I also stand on there and they,
they,
they're like,
this never happened.
This stuff that you just said never
happened.
This left this left wing stuff that we
agree on.
Never happened because you don't believe
in because you have this one thing that
we have a problem with
about it.
But you're not being clear about that.
Like,
what,
what is the issue?
Um,
I wanted it comes to small government,
like you wanting small government.
What's the opposition to that?
What do they say?
Well,
they say like a,
they make a of it's insinuations because
a lot of it isn't even things that I
feel or believe.
So an example would be,
um,
you know,
I see a lot of people say all the time,
like a column doesn't believe in welfare
or column doesn't believe in,
in social security.
I'm like,
I never said that actually.
I just,
I believe that these things should be
reformed and maybe take it back a step.
But they even look at that as a push too
far on the,
on the system.
I guess what I'm trying to say to you,
and I'm sorry I'm not being more lucid
with you,
I'm trying my hardest is,
is that they're,
they,
you have to agree with them lockstep.
If they see you in one way that is,
that is,
is injurious to their cars or two that
is conflicting or contrary to what they
believe.
They do not give a fuck about anything
else you believe.
And that's the thing that always
frustrated me and what so surprising you
with them.
The people were really were running me
out on a rail out of the gaming industry
with the,
with a completely innocuous joke,
which I think tells you everything you
need to know about the the intent that
they don't see.
They don't want allies in different
ways.
Allies in different close allies and
that they want just.
They just want complete,
you know,
it's very orwellian.
They just want you to be completely like
them and if you're not like then they
don't want anything to do with you and
it's these and it's not even like I was
advocating for anything crazy.
I don't advocate for anything crazy.
I don't think
that doesn't sound crazy at all.
But what's interesting is we've kind of
turned a corner where in many ways the
right is more tolerant than the left to
variations in their ideology.
Whereas the right is much more tolerant
to people that support gay marriage.
The right is much more tolerant to
people.
That,
I mean this is.
You fill in the blanks.
There's a bunch of different rights that
the right would sort of accept from
someone who also voted Republican,
but the left isn't like if,
if you got to the point where like I got
into a heated argument with someone
wants about abortion,
which I'm pro choice,
but what I was saying,
well essentially,
but obviously it was a criticism of
Richard Dawkins quote where he's
comparing a human embryo to a,
a pig fetus or a pig embryo.
I forget what the terms of use,
but I'm like,
well that's ridiculous because one of
them is going to become a person if you
don't take it out of your body.
And that was the idea behind it.
Like you can't,
you can't use that sort of an analogy
because it's not true.
I mean it's just one has the potential
for being a person and I was being
accused by this guy of being right wing
because of it.
And I was like,
well,
I'm not right wing.
I'm just talking about the potential for
life.
Like a pig embryo is never going to be
my neighbor Mike.
It's just not.
You know what I mean?
But that baby,
I'm not saying you should be forced to
make that baby a person and keep it in
your body when it's a few cells and then
two weeks old and then sit you.
I'm not saying that you can't choose
when to terminate your pregnancy,
but what I'm saying is you're
terminating a pregnancy.
We both know what you're doing.
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to
do it,
but to pretend that it's not messy and
nobody wants it to be messy.
Nobody wants to be a complicated issue.
They wanted to be cut and dry.
If you're on the left in particular,
it's pro choice,
a woman's reproductive choice,
freedom of your body to do what you
want.
I get all that.
I'm 100 percent with you,
but let's.
Let's not lie about what it is because
as soon as we know,
as soon as we distort the reality of
what the thing is,
then we put up these ideological
boundaries and blinders and we make
communication very difficult and we make
these rigid ideologies almost like a
religion.
They are almost like dogma.
And when you do it,
put it.
I mean,
when you do that,
you have real problems because people
can't communicate,
so if someone does bring that up and
say,
well,
you know,
what is abortion?
And then silence across the dinner table
you hear people dropping their forks and
like,
what is abortion?
What are you doing?
You're at what age is it okay to have an
abortion?
At what age is it?
Not.
Okay.
Is it okay to abort a baby a day before
it's born?
No.
Okay.
So a but a month before?
No.
How about two months before?
How about three?
How about four?
How about five?
How about six?
How about seven?
Where do we.
You know what I'm saying?
Where do we get to the point where it's
not a baby and I think that's a viable
conversation and it's a real.
It's a very uncomfortable discussion.
As soon as you like me saying it right
now,
there's people listening to this right
now that are in their car.
Maybe there's a woman listening to this.
It's had an abortion and she's like,
I don't want to hear this,
and she wants to shut it off.
Maybe there's a guy who's trying to
pressure his wife or girlfriend into
having an abortion and he doesn't want
to hear it,
but what is it?
What is abortion?
What is it?
Right?
It's,
it's,
and this is what I always call it the,
this,
this issue,
to me particularly joe is a 60 40 issue.
What I always say is like,
I am pro choice,
but I respect the prolife argument and I
don't think you should just have
unfettered access to abortions forever.
You know,
like,
you know,
yeah.
Two months,
you know,
something like that.
Fourteen week,
I don't know,
I don't know what the number would be,
what the number is.
Fourteen weeks to months,
but to me I'm like,
yeah,
what's happened when you make a great
point?
Because it's,
it's,
it is this dogmatic sense of saying like
it.
Here's the way it is.
That's it.
It goes back to the,
you know,
I heard you talking about it.
I was so.
I was so glad to hear you say it because
it goes back to like the war on women,
right?
Like there's just a whole group of
people apparently in the country,
a hundred 50 million of them.
I hate women that,
that because they're pro prolife for
instance,
which is a stance I don't share,
but I respect.
Why does that mean that they hate women?
Why does it mean that like why does it
always go from zero to 10 for like
immediately it's like.
And then there's all these lies mixed in
like the um,
uh,
the,
the pay gap,
which is a fucking lie.
Just lie.
It's not just a lot.
It's a lot is perpetrated by Obama on TV
talking about it.
I mean,
it's such a
confusing lie.
It's just bizarre.
It is demonstrably false and it is a
lie.
So why do I heat here?
Keep it.
Why does everyone want be so divisive?
Why do you want to add more fuel to the
fire when you can be like,
hey,
maybe we have problem x,
Y,
and Z,
but this isn't a problem.
Actually,
I saw it again recently.
It was recently in the news.
Somebody brought it up and it unchecked
and unchallenged.
Just explain to people if there were,
because I've done it too many times,
explained to people what the real pay
gap is and what the issue is when,
why it's using it incorrectly,
so the pay gap claimed by studies,
I guess the Department of Labor or
something is twenty one cents or
something like that.
So I was saying I think something like
70,
every dollar a man makes a woman makes
seventy nine cents.
That's true.
Only if you take every man,
every woman take all of the money they
make and divided by the amount of men in
the amount of women doesn't take into
account a careers,
doesn't take into account personal
choices.
Women for instance,
leave the workforce to have families.
Sometimes men are gravitating towards
engineering or physics or things that
pay them a lot of money while women tend
to,
you know,
tend maybe towards psychology or
something like that.
I think the argument is something like
nine out of the 10 top grossing career
choices are men dominated and nine out
of the 10 lowest Korea money making
career choices are actually dominated by
women.
I think the only exception there is
clergy which is dominated by men and so,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't adjust for any of these
things,
so when you actually adjust for choices,
when you adjust for careers and
longevity and hours and all of these
things that are relevant,
the pay gap closes to something like
less than five cents and then there's
even arguments saying that those could
probably be explained away completely as
well depending on what I know Christina
Summers and some of the.
Some of these people that know way more
about this and I do have videos about if
you actually dive in,
you probably can get rid of the entire
number completely,
but the the,
the prosperous to say that the woman
makes seventy nine cents for every
dollar
peated ad nauseum.
The real issue is there.
It's implying that two people working
alongside each other at the apple store,
the man is making $5 an hour.
The woman is making seventy nine cents
an hour less.
Yeah.
Than seventy nine cents per dollar less.
Right?
It's just not true.
Like significantly.
And I liked the argument because it's
true.
You know why not,
why if that was true,
why wouldn't a corporation just hire
women?
Seventy nine percent,
I should say it right?
Seventy nine cents to every dollar the
manmade makes.
Just corporations would Holler,
hire women if they were just as
competent,
just as skilled,
and it's not that.
It's also men are more likely to die on
the job.
Men will more likely to pick way more
dangerous careers like forest fighting,
forest firefighting,
whether it's a coal mining,
all those things are dominated by men
and a lot of people die and I'm law
enforcement of course,
who's A.
There's a bunch of issues with it,
but the problem is it's.
It's spewed out as an indication that we
are an inherently sexist society and
whether or not you can find sexism in
our society,
I'm sure you can do it absolutely
exists.
Just as racism exists,
I don't think it is nearly as much of a
problem as they're trying to pin it out
to me and I think there's a lot of other
factors involved in why men make more
money and one of them may be the demand
for a higher salary when they're being
hired.
Better skills at negotiation or more
confidence in those sorts of
confrontations with employers or
negotiations with employers.
I mean there's a lot of factors but it
doesn't do anybody any good to repeat a
false statistic when it's provably false
and then when people find out that it's
false and then they lose confidence in
the information they're being given,
it it.
It's also.
I think that's one half of the other
half of it is like what does it say
about a person that just continues to
say it anyway,
right?
Like at some point,
truth doesn't matter anymore.
Right?
Like I want to have.
I want to have factual debates.
I want to have like this is the
starting,
these are objective truths and then less
debate about those things.
Right.
But if that's your starting point,
if that's like a third of the entire
reason why you're angry and in the
streets in Washington DC,
well then I don't even know what you're
angry about anymore to be honest.
It's the same.
It goes back to like occupy Wall Street
or all these things where I'm like,
I don't know exactly what you're angry
about and this is why this,
this protest isn't working and isn't
resonating with.
Yeah.
I saw people in the march for women,
the women's march thing with signs
talking about the gender pay gap.
And so they had the time to make a sign.
They had the time to take that sign and
nail it to some boards and carry it
around.
But they didn't have time to Google
whether or not that was true.
They,
this fascinating.
That's also fine.
And I feel like some of them have to
know,
right?
Some of them they don't want to know,
man.
It's like I've read this thing once that
said that a sperm cures depression in
women.
And uh,
I didn't even look any further on micro
got all the information I need.
This,
I don't want to just debunk,
I want to be rock solid in my approach,
shut the laptop and walked out of the
room.
I mean,
that's really what's going on.
It's like,
that sounds great.
If women make seventy nine cents to
every dollar man makes it sounds
awesome.
This is a bullshit society.
This,
the patriarchy.
What?
Patriarchy.
Meanwhile,
you asked them,
you know,
you,
you ask,
uh,
one of these feminists,
there's a reason with feminism if,
if,
if the goal is for total equality,
but we all know that that's now where
really what feminism means to that,
you know,
if you sit there and be like,
can you name just one thing that I can
do that you can't just one,
like,
like one,
and I'm not saying like you give birth,
I can or something like something
biological.
I'm saying like,
what can't you do?
Like,
like if you really want it to.
I'm not saying that,
you know,
like I,
I know for instance that um,
you know,
the,
the examples that people give,
and I haven't seen the statistics,
but I've heard it circulated that even
that,
you know,
companies are so desperate to hire women
because of this,
this situation,
this optical situation that they're in
where it seems like women are being
pushed down that women in their twenties
and thirties,
we're actually making more now.
You know,
that they're certainly,
they're more likely to get a higher
education.
Certainly they're more likely be,
you know,
even graduate high school.
So there are actually systemic benefits
to being a woman and there's nothing
necessarily wrong with that either.
But I just feel like it goes,
goes back to that thing of like,
why are we fighting?
Like,
what is the divisive nature,
can't we.
And this goes back to your question
about the video game industry.
I'm like,
Hey,
instead of yelling at me about this,
we won't agree about this,
these situations over here,
but can we advocate for these together?
Or do you not want to,
you wanna you wanna you don't want my
advocacy for gay marriage because I
believe in small government,
you all my advocacy for a,
you know,
transgender rights because I'm for low
taxes,
just like,
I'm like,
okay,
that's weird because we can totally be
friends here with the women's March.
I know that there were problems with pro
life organizations getting involved at a
sponsorship level even.
Oh Wow.
And uh,
it's like they're not women.
They're,
they,
they're,
they're lesser than debate
about that one issue.
Yeah.
Strange.
You said something that I want to go
back to what,
what do you think feminism is about?
What's his argument about,
about equality?
I mean,
to me,
feminism was about equality and I think
that this,
this,
you know,
I'm reading more about it and learning
more about it,
so I'm still very ignorant about it.
But this third wave,
what they call it,
third wave feminism,
which I'm sure is a term you've heard,
that seems to be more about a combative
nature to actually,
you know,
instead of like saying like men and
women are equal,
men and women should deserve the same
rights and the same treatment and all
those kinds of things.
It's actually seems to be very anti man
in a way.
Like it seems to be very,
like almost like the tables have turned,
you know,
and I'm like,
well why are you turning the tables like
we didn't have you achieve what you want
in like in the first place,
which was just that we were going to be
here together at the,
you know,
at the,
at the nexus of everything as two
genders.
Problem is that reinforcing that fake
statistic,
the,
the gender pay gap that so many people
have heard that.
Like Sarah Silverman was just talking
about a recently and some,
some big thing that she did.
I'm like,
that's not true,
but yet people just say it and no one
stops them from Santa.
A friend of mine that was a very
educated guy said it,
we were having a debate about a divorce
and he brought it up and I was like,
that's not even true,
and unfortunately we're in a place with
no cell phone reception,
so I had to wait until we got back to
send it to them.
Like this is not true.
Like what you're saying is not true.
Like you're repeating it as if you know,
but meanwhile you've done zero research
on it.
It's a talking point that just gets
reiterated over and over again without
any research and it's convenient.
It's convenient to reinforce your
argument.
It's a number.
It's a number that deals with a very
complex and nuanced debate and I think
that the idea of feminism is to me in a
lot of ways,
very similar to the idea of the men's
rights movement.
I'm not opposed to rights for anybody.
I'm not opposed to anyone.
I'm very egalitarianism ideas about the
world,
but I am opposed to anybody that likes
one gender over the other because I
think that's foolish.
Just like I'm opposed to people that
only like white people.
I'm going to pose to people that only
like black people,
I'm opposed to people that generalize
based on an enormous mass of human
beings.
Like men are shit,
women rule,
girls rule,
boys drool.
You know,
I,
I don't like it the other way either.
I don't like it that he man,
woman haters club.
I don't like.
I don't like any ideologies that lump
people into these huge groups because I
think it's more on think.
I think it's a stupid way of looking at
the world.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I,
I'm,
I'm the same way that the yellow tarian
nature is the best that the,
the,
uh,
live and let live nature to judge people
based on their character and the quality
of their intelligence or whatever it is
you're looking for in them.
Shouldn't be categorized in these
specific ways by sex or gender or by
race or religion by any of those kinds
of things.
I'm totally with you there,
but I think we both agree that women
shouldn't be allowed to vote,
right?
I mean,
yeah,
I mean that was a.
women have suffered long enough,
enough already at girls I used to.
I used to think that joke was so funny.
You want mean you get murdered for that
joke today with like the women's
suffrage suffragettes like women have
suffered long enough instead of
suffering whatever.
And I was like,
it's a funny joke.
I'd probably,
that would've ruined my career to,
on twitter,
but uh,
it didn't ruin your career.
It just,
it gave you a platform.
Honestly,
it's all,
it all balances out.
It's slow.
As long as you're being attacked for
something that's not valid,
it all balances out.
It just takes.
You take a little heat and then you
realize like,
okay,
I'm through that.
Yeah.
It was scary for a little while.
It was scary.
I don't know if scary is the right word.
It's,
it was,
it was uncomfortable.
It was uncomfortable and unsettling.
And you really saw where everyone stood.
Right?
So one of the things I was talking with
people about was,
you know,
how sad it was for me that no,
like very few people that I knew came to
my defense and I wasn't saying they had
to come to my defense and be like,
uh,
Collin,
you know,
that joke was fine.
Like,
if you didn't like the joke,
that's,
I don't care.
It's fine.
Jokes fall flat all the time.
You know,
that you're a comedian.
It's,
it's hard.
I don't do it professionally.
I mean it's impossibly hard to get on
the stage and do that kind of stuff.
But to me I was like,
hey,
is anyone going to say that I'm not a
sexist?
Is anyone going to stand up that's known
me for 10 years and say like,
Hey,
we don't agree with the joke,
but the way you're categorizing this guy
who I know is not accurate.
And I heard that there were some fights
behind the scenes with people and I got
a lot of DMZ messages but very little in
terms of public support.
And that really hurt me.
Like that really,
really hurt me and wounded me in a deep
way and ruin friendships like that I had
for years,
like fake friendship
man,
and you know,
and people probably felt the need to toe
the line,
you know,
toe this,
I don't want to say party line,
but the ideological ideological line
mean the dogmatic line if you,
if you run into someone who is in any
way involved in any sort of a dispute
that makes that person appear to be a
sexist,
you're supposed to pile on.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that's exactly what they did.
And the thing that hurt me the most is
that I didn't expect it.
I'm not close with a lot of these
people,
but people that know me,
you know,
there are people in this industry that
are writing that we're piling on me or
remaining silent that got freelance work
because of me that got maybe even got
hired because I was on a hiring
committee that put,
you know,
push for them.
Uh,
all of these kinds of things that people
used to take out to lunch when I was
senior editor to see how they were
doing,
if there's anything I can do for them,
stuff like that.
And everyone's just like,
no,
not going to stay.
I'm not going to come back and help help
him out now.
And I tried to put that good energy out
there.
I'm not always full of good energy.
Sometimes I say negative things or bad
things.
Sometimes they make mistakes,
but when it comes,
when a person comes after your character
and you damn well know that there are a
bunch of people around you that know who
you are,
whether or not they agree with what you
said or agree with what you do,
but they know you're who you are.
And they know the severity of what
people are saying and they don't say
anything that really wounds a person and
that really fucking hurt.
Do you think?
I think
that what's going on and a lot of ways
when people did not come to your defense
is that what you're doing,
um,
in,
in many ways is making a very
complicated and nuanced perspective from
a person in your,
in your stance,
you're,
you're kind of,
you're taking this,
this,
this path outside of the ideology and by
doing so you sort of challenge a lot of
the ways these people have been behaving
for a long time and as soon as you do
that,
they have to kind of reconsider these
ideological boundaries that you've set
up and their own behavior and thinking
and communication and that they don't
want to do that and they,
they don't want to do that.
Like to keep things rigid and simple and
they also want to continue to progress
in their career.
And in order to do that you have to kind
of like have this predetermined pattern
that you follow.
I think simple is the key word that
simple because yes they can.
There are people out there that can not
comprehend how a person who believes in
small government,
for instance,
we'll use the same argument that says
the government can't touch my guns.
That's consistent with saying the
government can't tell a woman what to do
with her body that's consistent with
principle.
It says,
I'm a government shouldn't even be
involved in telling you who you can
marry in the mannequin.
Could she be able to marry a man and a
woman should be able to marry a woman
and I would go as far as to say that
even a polygamist totally on the,
on the up and up,
everyone's in on it.
Relationship should not be the
government.
The that of course,
they cannot acknowledge that it's the
lack of governmental power that gives
you that.
Right?
In my perspective,
when they feel like it's the wielding of
government power that ensures those,
those rights,
that's not the.
That's not congruent with them.
They don't understand how the how,
how.
We don't understand how we came to the
same exact conclusion by going just
totally two different directions and
that really that challenges them and
they don't have the philosophical
boundary bounding to figure out how that
might be.
No.
Well,
that's the argument that the philosophy
has to be bound in writing has to be
bound in some sort of a doctrine.
It has to be written down on paper and
established and enforced by a government
that's.
That's like a big daddy thing,
you know?
I mean instead of saying,
give the power to the people,
let people do whatever they would like
to do as long as they're not infringing
upon the rights of others and let's have
less and less people dictating what
people get to do.
Right,
and that's,
that to me is liberty and they and they
look at it or I don't want to say that,
but a lot of people,
a lot of progressives are regressives
men.
They only want to look at them.
We'll look at it and be like,
well,
the government has one shared these
things because these are not natural.
These are not natural rights are.
These are not things that can be insured
and I'm like,
but in the national society and the
natural sense,
we have to have a consistent rights.
I can't in good faith say like I have
the right to wield a gun because the
government can't tell me that even
though it's enshrined in the bill of
rights,
but then say like,
oh,
the government can get involved in your
bedroom though.
All of the garment can tap your phone.
Oh,
the government.
I'm like,
no,
it's either all or nothing and if you
and if,
if that's.
If that's a philosophy that's too hard
for people to wrap their minds around
and I don't know what to say about that,
but to me it's.
It's to me it's pretty clear and pretty
lucid the way I feel.
My principals are rooted in that
philosophy.
Also.
I think when people there,
they're seeking this sort of comfort
level in,
in life and in,
in,
in their positions and I don't
necessarily think people understand that
as soon as you allow the government to
much power,
you will never get that back.
As soon as they have power.
As soon as they can take away some of
your liberties,
those will never get returned or one of
the rare ones is marijuana.
It is a really.
Well,
it was.
I was trying to explain to someone the
other day about this,
like it's incredibly rare that something
becomes legal that was illegal.
As long as marijuana.
It's very rare,
like something has be in a just
completely undeniably good for it to
have gone through all the propaganda,
all the bullshit,
all the lies,
all the governmental regulations.
So the people being locked up in jail
for life or and then still come out the
other side on 2017 and be legal and a
bunch of states recreationally.
Yeah.
Not even just medically.
It's great to see,
but it's fascinating because it's one of
the rare instances where liberty last is
regained and most of the time it's not.
It's just not.
It's an aberration and that's what
people have to be really scared of and
that's.
That goes to the point.
It's like I don't want to give anything
an inch because I am afraid of the
consequences of giving anyone an inch.
That's why I wouldn't apologize for the
joke,
that's why I resigned from my company
instead of apologizing for the joke.
Wow.
Could you apologize for that?
So first of all,
it's a honeymooners married with
children all in the family level jokes,
something you'd see on the floor of a
CBS writers room and it and,
but uh,
but the point is that I could have
probably apologizing for,
but I'm like,
no because a,
I'm not sorry.
So that'll be a huge lie.
Be Like I have to now really recalibrate
the way I go about my business with,
you know,
with my partners and with the audience
because,
you know,
I didn't have the protections that I
thought I would have when,
when the mistake was made,
you know what I mean?
Like I didn't and that was what hurt me.
So I,
I tried to do what I thought was the
most principled and character driven
choice which would be like,
this is best for my partners who don't
agree with me.
This is best for the audience who might
not agree with me.
It seems like a lot of them do.
And this is the best for just everyone
moving forward.
I'll have other opportunities and other
things that I can do.
Has it been any blowback,
um,
targeted towards the people that were
upset at you?
Yes.
Uh,
and the thing that,
the,
you know,
it's sad to see because it's not in my
eye.
I feel like I'm a pretty good natured
person and I don't like CP seeing that
rubber band effect going on where people
now are suffering because they stood up
and stood out or whatever.
It's just that.
And I don't care about the people that
were out to character assassinate me.
I'm talking about like,
you know,
my and my business partners and stuff.
It's just that like,
no matter what I say will be twisted.
I tried to be very magnanimous and like
very kind about it when I was on Ruben
the second time and people twisted
everything to just be a problem anyway.
So I'm like,
I'll just remain silent because I'd
rather than misconstrue the silence that
misconstrue the words,
you know?
Um,
is that
problem?
No,
the,
if you,
if you're not communicating freely and
because you're worried about the
repercussions,
I'm not worried about the repercussions.
For me,
I'm worried about foisting repercussions
on other people that have no control
over what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But even even that,
it's like it's not your responsibility
as long as you're communicating in an
honest way.
Sure.
I mean you're thinking that's sort of
the same reason why people didn't come
to your support in the first place
because they were worried that if they
spoke their mind,
they would be targeted.
If they said,
hey,
you know,
I know that this is going on.
I think Collins,
a great guy,
I don't think he's sexist and my feeling
on them is that it was just a joke and
then they could get targeted and they
chose not to.
They chose not to step up and,
and a lot of ways you not speaking your
mind in a clear way sort of sets that
same sort of tone.
I think you should be able to speak
freely and I think you should be held
responsible for when you say something
and irresponsible like it's or it's
wrong or it's hurtful in some ways and
people make mistakes like that all the
time and there's also we have to take
into account that a lot of times people
don't realize the consequences of their
words or they say things in a flippant
manner or they're tired or they're
stressed or things come out that they
don't necessarily believe in that way,
but especially when it comes to like
something like twitter or some short
form short paragraphs sort of a thing.
I think it's really important that we be
given the opportunity to express
ourselves fully and then the
disagreements with that be categorized
in an honest way and what I had the most
problem with was not just someone
calling you a racist,
but everyone was making it out to be
this horrible,
sexist,
evil thing.
When it's clearly something said in jest
and as soon as you can.
And that's my wheelhouse.
As soon as you start taking humor and
something that people say that it's
absolutely meant to be just funny and
make it as like the,
Oh,
this guy just signed an affidavit that
women should shut the fuck up because
it's better.
I mean,
that's really the worst case scenario.
Interpretation of what you said.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
yeah,
I think that that was the disappointing
part of it was again,
it goes back to this point of like
ignored everything.
Like my body of work,
the things that I actually stood up very
loudly for political and social causes.
Many times there are huge videos I have
of the things that my feelings on the
confederate flag or like how I feel
like.
What did you think about the confederate
flag?
I think that you have the right to fly
it.
I just think it's in terrible taste and
I understand why people were upset about
it and I don't think it should be in.
I don't think the flag of a trader is
country.
It should be instituted in state flags
in the United States.
He's your dad I think is absolutely
valid.
Do you think that it's legal,
is it legal to have a Nazi flag?
Is it
almost wants to go?
Yeah,
I would.
I only see why it wouldn't be legal to
have the confederate flag,
but you just can't have it on the Dukes
of hazzard.
Well,
to me it's like I'm not talking about
the legality of it because if you want
to fly a swastika out your house,
you're allowed to.
I think you should probably be allowed
to do that.
I don't think.
I think you're an absolute idiot for
doing that,
but that's your right to be an idiot.
But the confederate flag thing was just
a sign for me because it was,
it was this,
uh,
this,
this juxtaposition of saying,
look,
well we're talking about the legal
rights,
but actually I'm talking about the
taste,
right?
You know,
like say like,
people don't remember what the CSA was.
I don't think a lot of people even fly
that flag and know what the hell they're
flying this country seceded from the
United States.
They were traders and or their Leonard
skinner fence,
or they're huge Leonard skinner advance
a huge big and Mississippi like,
you know,
but to me I'm like,
we have to have,
let's,
let's put this in historicity.
Let's think about what we're doing here.
This country left to protect its slaves.
It's right to own slaves.
Any other interpretation of it is wrong
based on,
on what was going on in the 18 fifties
and leading up to 18,
60 these states' rights advocate and all
that.
That's not what it was about economics.
It's not what it was about.
It wasn't about states' rights,
it wasn't about any of those things.
It was about your ability.
Your economy would have fallen apart
without free labor.
And these people left.
They caused a gratuitously bloody war
and then they were let me know both
Abraham Lincoln and then Andrew Johnson,
just let them back in,
you know,
uh,
Jefferson Davis who was the president of
the confederacy,
wasn't murdered.
He wasn't executed,
you know,
like they were all back in.
And for some reason,
because reconstruction went the way it
did into the,
into the ulysses s grant,
kind of a era of presidency,
people look at it and be like,
well,
things kind of ended good and they're
kind of like brothers again.
And I'm like,
that's not really the way it was with
Jim crow came up and stuff like that.
This fucking flag means something,
the Pfarius and you can't.
So it's your right to fly it.
And if you feel like that's a southern
pride thing,
more power to.
I love the south.
I think the south awesome south needs
another flag.
But yeah,
you would need to.
You need to know what this flag means to
people.
You guys left,
you guys killed hundreds of thousands of
people doing it and,
and you just fly.
This flag is like the south will rise
again.
No,
it won't.
Don't you think that that's a bad
expression.
The south will rise again is a terrible
But I think that a lot of people look at
that flag and it represents what we're
calling southern pride,
which is nothing wrong.
Nothing wrong with being proud of being
from Georgia or wherever the fuck your
friends states down there.
Yeah,
but I think the,
the issue is what it means to other
people you know,
and whether or not that's valid when
you're not talking about like touchy
feely,
like people being oversensitive.
Now you're talking about a horrible war
about slavery.
It's like probably one of the worst
kinds of wars like a war because we
would like to keep people in prison and
working for free.
So we're willing to kill other people
over it to fight for that.
Right.
This is essentially what it was.
So it's to the people of today,
it doesn't seem like that because
they're not living in 1850,
they're not in the days when you know,
they have these massive like,
like Gettysburg or they have these
massive areas where people would be
slaughtered.
I mean this people to this day,
that's still fine.
Like civil war shit where they had these
massive battles and they can dig through
the ground with metal detectors and they
find bullets and guns and badges and
awesome.
It's great.
I mean,
I,
I took the idea from a saving private
Ryan,
the guy that would take dirt from all
the battlefields,
that they would go to them,
put it in,
put it in jars,
he and you put it.
They only showed it once in the movie,
but I used to go to all these
battlefields when I was a kid because I
was fascinated by my parents would bring
me in,
I would take,
I would go buy baby food and dumped them
out and then go to all the battlefields
and put dirt on each of them and put
them on.
Oh,
that's heavy.
Yeah.
I like this.
When you were a kid.
Yeah,
like my in my teens and early twenties.
Yeah.
So you've always been into this.
Yes.
Since I was,
uh,
my earliest memory is of being in the
politics and history was,
was the Gulf War,
which was 99,
kind of the lead up to it with Kuwait
and stuff.
90 91.
So I was like six or seven.
I remember,
you know,
Newsday,
as Long Island newspaper,
I remember just seeing images and kind
of maps and,
and I didn't really understand what was
going on.
I couldn't even read most of the words.
I mean,
it's complicated geopolitical stuff
they're talking about,
but I ever since that point I was very
politically focused on my dad is a
staunch,
like Rockefeller Republican,
like a Paleo con,
like a moderate Republican,
um,
in the old north,
you know,
people out there right now.
But like Republicans are pretty
disparate group,
like Republicans in New England are.
Republicans in New York are very
different than Republicans in Texas,
but they're both Republicans and my dad
grew up just in,
you know,
giving me things to read and,
and feeding that fire and by me maps and
buying me books and we will listen to
talk radio and we would debate things
and we would kind of come to these
conclusions of different things.
And we disagree with that.
A lot of things still to this day.
But he's a great man.
And uh,
ever since then I was really,
really interested in.
I knew when I was fourth or fifth grade
that I would study history and I
remember in New York we have this thing
called the regions in high school which
are like these tests,
these state run tests you have to pass
to graduate,
so like you would take your class but
then you have to take your final,
but then you have to take a regents exam
which is the state run thing,
say like,
you know,
math,
whatever.
And I remember when I was in sixth grade
and my sister alley who is six years
older than me,
it was taking the US history regents
like the next few days from then.
And I helped her study and I,
and like I remember like she didn't know
any really anything she needed to know
and I taught her like what she needed to
know just for this very rudimentary
test.
And that was stuck in my mind where I
was like,
the,
I have a real passion for this.
I really like it.
I enjoy it.
I don't know everything.
I make mistakes sometimes and I changed
the way I feel sometimes,
but it's always been a real,
real fascinating.
Now that you've left your company,
the which was,
wow,
what was it called?
Kind of fun.
Kind of funny.
Yeah,
and what was kind of funny,
kind of funny was the four of us that
founded the company were all at ign in
different respects and we spun off to
just start our own youtube channel about
games and nerd culture and stuff like
that,
do podcasts and we found some good
success,
almost a crowdfunded on Patrion and it
was a lot of fun.
Then I enjoyed it,
but I felt like I needed to leave
because I felt like that was the best
for everybody.
Well,
once that.
I mean,
how could you not if he turned on you
over that stupid fucking joke.
Yeah,
I mean it's like,
it was a stupid joke.
It was a bad joke,
but I mean it's not even that bad.
No,
I appreciate that.
That means a lot coming from you.
I looked at it.
That's stupid.
The reaction to it was so fucking
stupid.
It was stupid and I felt like,
you know,
I wish that I wish that things went
differently.
I wish that,
you know,
we had a lot of fights behind the
scenes.
I won't get into all that.
I don't think.
I honestly think it's good.
I think it's good to.
I don't,
I don't know.
I,
I felt like I did what was right for
them and I felt like we would have just
come to this impasse again.
So I was like,
let's just pull the bandaid off and get
to get this over with.
Are you going to do something that
involves politics now?
Because clearly you have a deep passion
for this.
Yeah.
I started a,
uh,
a new youtube channel that the first
video about April third.
It's called Colin's last stand.
Um,
and crazy.
It's already funded on Patrion 38,
$38,000 a mind for.
Well,
it's.
People are committing an expression.
I do it.
Yeah,
because I think it's powerful.
Like there are things worth dying for
things worth risking.
There it is.
So I,
I reached $39,000 a month and it's going
to fall $39,000 a month.
People it's going to fall.
I'm sure it's going to fall.
People.
Shit Dude.
People are talking.
People are responding to my this holy
Shit.
That's a lot of fucking money.
30 nine grand a month.
You're going to get $39,000 a month and
you haven't even started yet.
Yeah,
technically.
But it's going to fall back down to the
teens.
Probably relaxed with your humility will
take it down.
If you scroll here,
you'll see on the left side,
underneath the number.
My stretch goal is to reach $10,000.
So my,
my,
my expectations were blown out of the
water and I really.
What I read into the show is,
is,
is you know,
people are just sick of this bullshit.
This is them,
this is them speaking and being like we
need a conduit that's going to get into
the history and get into the philosophy
and the politics.
But also that will stand up and say
like,
I'm not sorry for a joke.
People have the right to make mistakes.
People have the right to express
themselves.
It goes back to the confederate flag
thing.
I might disagree with a person that
flies that flag,
but I'm not going to go wrap up on their
door and pull it off and call them a
racist.
I'm just going to shake my head and
walk,
you know,
because there are other things to worry
about.
So it's people that like want more
liberty focused,
individual focused kind of things and
that's just people speaking to me,
you know,
so.
So the number will fall back down after
the month.
I'm sharing.
That's fine.
Just stop synchronet drive me crazy with
this fake humility.
It's not humility out.
Actually I remember I was going to fall.
No,
people are gonna like me less but,
but,
but my,
my whole Dad's side,
it's really not fake humility.
It's me saying like,
I hear you and I'll do my very best to
do this.
The numbers keep going up.
The problem is everyone's going to know
what the numbers are and they're going
to go out or I need to give him any
money.
He's making $39,000 a month.
That's fine,
that's not fine.
She'd hide that number.
Can you hide it?
You can,
but I feel like I want to be.
I want to be,
I want to be honest with people and oh
my God,
if you weren't patrion you'd frigging
kill.
Got to get that cash the sun.
But yeah,
you kind of hide it,
but I want it to be totally transparent.
What I keep telling people is,
as long as we keep a level of
sustainable level of money,
which is way less than what I have now,
there'll be no baked and adds,
no product placements,
none of that.
And I want people to know I want,
I want people to be involved in the,
in it from.
It's.
So Colin's last stand is about politics.
It's going to be.
Yeah.
So I want to do two videos a week
between 10 and 15 minutes long each that
are scripted and written.
Um,
and I know how to edit and something.
I'm very good at it.
The quality of the videos,
uh,
from a,
from an ethical perspective,
you'll find better quality.
But I want the content to be really
good.
And so I want to just do two videos a
week,
one probably focused on history and one
probably focused on politics.
So one that's more rooted in,
in philosophy that I'll go research and
write.
I'm already researching and writing the
first one.
I don't want to ruin it for anyone yet,
but I think it'd be really fun.
And then the second,
maybe the second video every week will
be something about what's happening in
the world and I'll talk to a camera and
just be like,
this is the way I feel about this.
This is maybe why I feel this way.
And just.
And just some stuff out there.
You know,
I want to treat people's time with care.
I don't have the brand you have.
I don't have,
you know,
people that are,
that are religious about listening to
everything I do.
So I want people to like look forward to
saying like,
Oh,
twice a week column.
I put up a 10 minute video that I can
just,
when I'm making dinner,
just listened to it in the background
and then go about my day and maybe learn
something or maybe feel a certain way or
maybe I disagree and then move on and,
and,
and have it just be a part of people's
lives.
And that.
So clearly you've put a lot of thought
into this and you've thought this
through obviously something you're
really planning out.
Well,
yeah,
I'm trying.
I mean that was actually the one,
the number kept rising.
I was horrified like at first because I
was like,
because I was like,
I have that ability.
Like I hate money though.
It was of course I love money but I,
I,
it's like the imposter syndrome where
you never really know that you're
earning it or whatever.
And I'm like,
I want,
I don't want to let anyone down.
I only have right now the intro video,
which is just me talking to the camera
kind of with what my plan is.
I'm trying to really keep people engaged
and putting update videos on and letting
them know where everything is.
Um,
but yeah,
it was horrified because I'm like,
you know,
I only have the bandwidth to do two
videos a week,
whether I'm making $15,000 a month or
$40,000 a month.
And so if I put out a video to everyone
being like,
if this level sustained or even a level
that's in the twenties or thirties,
whatever it is,
I have to recalibrate what I'm thinking,
you know,
maybe I do hire someone to help me
shoot.
Maybe I do higher bandwidth.
What do you mean by a bank?
The bandwidth,
because I don't want people were like,
oh,
can we get a podcast?
Can we do more videos a week and stuff.
And I'm like,
that's not the vision for the product.
I only have enough bandwidth in my mind
to.
Right.
And it doesn't create time and space,
right.
And,
uh,
the money gives me means in the future
to maybe make the product more dynamic
or interesting or hire people and do
more.
But right now I just want to spend a few
months to like,
be like,
this is what I'm planning,
I want to write these things,
I want to put care into them.
I want to give you citations.
I wanna like have you give you further
things to read and all those kinds of
things.
And that takes time.
So you always like this,
like really hyped up and energetic.
Do you always have like this much
energy?
You always talk this fast.
I'm a fast talker.
That's in New York thing,
but I'm a.
I used to live in New York.
You didn't know a lot of people that
talked very fast.
They do it,
but you're like fucking ramped up.
It's because it's something I'm
passionate about.
You know,
it's A.
I don't mean to come off as annoying or
anything.
No,
no,
no.
You're not annoying at all.
It's impressive.
Thank you.
I just try to.
These are the things that I forgot for
so long in a way,
because I was writing about games,
which I love.
I Love Games.
I think they're important.
They're an important piece of escape.
They're an important piece of art.
I think that's all great,
but being able to engage with someone
like yourself with someone like Dave
Rubin or someone like a Steven crowder,
whoever it might be.
I was on Glenn Beck's radio show last
week.
It brings out an energy in me that I,
I didn't,
I was,
he wear boats.
I don't know.
I was on the phone,
so I have no,
he could have been naked for all and uh,
but it brings out an energy in me where
I'm like,
I can finally engage with people that
know what the fuck they're talking about
in this particular realm,
which I think is so exciting and so
interesting and we can have,
you know,
we had,
we debated,
we don't agree on everything.
I think that's awesome.
So that's really cool that you found,
uh,
a very big positive out of this.
Now you can express yourself more
honestly and you can,
you can gravitate towards your real
interests.
And yeah,
that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to use this as an opportunity
for myself and try and use it as an
opportunity to just carve out a little
slice of the Internet,
however big or small it might be,
where we can affect some positive change
and like an idea ideas and learning and
free expression and free thought and
making mistakes and disagreeing and all
that.
I think that's all great.
I want to use this as an example.
I want to get away from the Orthodoxy of
the gaming industry.
It's stifling and strangling and that's
what you think.
Let's go back to that because why do you
think it is like that?
Why is the gaming industry so hardcore
ideologically left wing progressive like
no variations?
No room for debate.
Why is that?
Well,
I think it's portrayed.
It's like it all gets funneled through a
media that is,
that is hyper liberal,
right?
So it's,
it's similar in a way to what's going on
with the media in news and politics.
These,
um,
you know,
underneath the surface of the gaming
industry are,
there are plenty of conservatives and
libertarians,
they,
they hide the.
Yeah,
they do.
A lot of them.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I was going to say,
a lot of them talk to me.
I mean,
I know people that are like heads of
studios that feel the way I do.
I know people that are in the trenches
at Qa and doing very menial things that
gaming studios,
I feel the way I do and everything in
between.
I remember a GDC game developer
conference in San Francisco,
which happens every spring.
Six or seven years ago,
a guy pulled me aside.
This the first time it ever happened to
me,
and this was when I was kind of starting
to make a name for myself and he pulled
me aside and he's like,
hey man,
I work at x,
Y andZ and um,
it works on a big game and he's like,
keep doing what you're doing.
There are a lot of people out there that
agree with what you're saying.
Um,
but they're,
they're,
they,
they don't dare speak out because
they'll get lambasted in some way.
Look what happened to me over something
so innocuous.
Well,
you there,
obviously you were saying that there is
some pushback about your ideas before
this.
Yes.
What did you experience?
Well,
so every time I would write a
politically driven an op Ed for
instance,
when I was at ign,
I had,
I was,
I was senior editor,
but I kinda had like editor at large
qualities were meaning for people I
don't know,
editor at large,
basically in a way do whatever they
want.
Like they'll find something to write
about.
I used to go away for days at a time and
over research things and then write
these big 50,000 word articles.
I'm 50,000 words.
Yeah.
The history of not that kind of time,
dude.
Well I,
I,
I did,
I carved it out.
But what about people reading it?
It was in five parts.
The history of naughty dog was like my
opus naughty dog's this very huge
actually in Santa Monica,
a very huge game developer,
very talented game developer.
I went and talked at 19 people,
got about a bunch of primary sources and
and all these things and wrote this
piece that I really cared about.
Um,
and so,
but when I would write things like the
political correctness piece about,
let me give you an example.
There's a game that was canceled a maybe
five years ago or so.
It was pretty late in development.
So it's weird to have to cancel a when
they've already spent a bunch of money
on it.
It was called six days in Fallujah and
it was a game about,
it was the third person shooter.
I think about,
uh,
the experience of Fallujah in Iraq,
you know,
terrible conflict that,
that happened there.
And people even on the right were
getting upset about being like,
it's too soon.
It's,
it's,
uh,
this is,
this is still ongoing,
how can you do?
And I wrote a piece being like,
what are you all saying?
Like,
this is awesome,
this is so great that someone wants to
tell a story like this and,
and,
and do something like this and you just
get it from all sides.
People will be like,
you know,
it's,
it's not sensitive.
It's,
it's all of these kinds of things.
And then the girlfriend mode thing I
wrote about where people were like,
oh,
you're a sexist and blah blah blah blah
blah.
And I'm like,
I'm actually just protecting the
sanctity of a man who might've made a
mistake.
That's it,
you know,
instead of destroying him,
it goes back to this whole thing of,
like the last year that,
I'm sorry,
the,
the girlfriend mode,
the borderlands story I told you you
were with the guy and they were all
going after him and going after his job
and do these things.
And I wrote a piece being like,
hey,
yeah,
like if this is a far skies,
like he made a mistake maybe and I don't
know that he should have is a soft
target and they just went after it.
Exactly.
And uh,
it reminds you that you experienced
blowback.
Yeah.
Every time from that.
Every time.
What was the blow back from that,
from you defending this guy saying,
well,
he just really fucked up the way he
described things,
but he was,
it was an innocent in that regard.
Well,
you lose like social cache when every
time it's something like this would
happen.
Right,
so that's why I say like this was the
moment,
the joke was the moment that they were
looking to pounce really,
and I'm not saying that they were
calculating,
everyone's waiting,
but they saw an opportunity and they
took it because over time you lose
respect over people because of your
political stances.
He completely reasonable political
stances I think where they remember that
you said this and he said this and he
said this doesn't really,
you weren't really having debates with
people where you were disagreeing with
them.
It was simply a matter of reaction to
some of the things that you had written
where they were trying to box you into
some sort of a conservative group.
Right.
And they would call me in,
you know,
now it's like I'm a Nazi,
I'm all right.
I'm,
I'm like,
I don't think,
I don't think I have one.
I don't think I've won outright.
I don't even really know what the alt
right means.
But like what,
like what is outright lying to me,
it seems like the far fringe is like the
Richard Spencer is of the world,
the Neo Nazis in the white supremacists
and the actual,
uh,
nationalists,
you know.
Well,
as soon as you write alt on something,
I feel like it's a message board thing.
Like,
all right,
it's like,
it's a,
it's a reddit thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
all right.
Alternative.
Right?
Like what is it?
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
I hope not based on their,
based on their,
based on their characterization of it,
but to me.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
No.
Well,
what is a,
what,
how would they define you as being alt
right?
What would they say that you have
outright characteristics.
You can see these,
you know,
a message boards for instance,
a lot of people were very supportive on
reddit and all these kinds of plays that
are a little more known for free
thought.
But there's this one video game,
a message board in particular,
um,
that is just insane.
And there was a hundred and 25 page or
so thread about me,
20 posts or I think it might even be 50
posts the page and I was reading it and
it hurts some of it because people are
like,
first of all,
people telling me I said things I never
said one thing.
People like Collins against his name is
no taxation is going to believe that
taxes should exist.
He often talk about how I really like
Ian Rand and I really like atlas
shrugged,
but I don't consider myself an
objectivist.
I don't believe that selfishness is
necessarily a virtue.
I just think she's interesting and I
think some of our ideas are interesting.
You know,
God forbid I exist somewhere in the gray
area,
but they're like collins and objective,
acidity,
selfish and blah blah blah.
And like collins a Nazi and he,
he's a racist.
He's a PSA.
I think the term,
a lot of the news with soft racist or
soft bigot,
soft race being like that.
He,
he doesn't,
he doesn't intentionally or actually
overtly say anything but supports causes
that are racist or sexist.
These are the kinds of characterizations
that were going on basically people
with,
on,
um,
on bulletin boards with,
with yarn and maps,
like that's how I picture them,
like trying to make continuous
connections and,
and,
and it's like these things aren't even
things I feel and,
and things that I said or being
taken out of context.
I often use the,
I'm in video games.
One of the big things is like,
you know,
there's a need for diverse casts and
diverse protagonists and stuff like
that.
And I often use the case that I used to
use the saying,
I don't believe in diversity for
diversity's sake.
I believe that an artist should tell his
story,
so of an artist,
a writer,
and have a game,
wants to have an all white cast and
that's what he thinks serves the story.
I don't think that makes them a racist.
If he wants to have an all Asian cast,
I don't think that makes them a racist
either.
I think that's what he wants to do.
Um,
and people took that out of context and
we're calling me a racist and a bigot.
And all these kinds of things and it's,
it's,
it's hurtful because there's no one
there to,
that.
No one's defending me,
you know,
and I can't,
I can't defend myself because I'll just
make it worse.
So it was kind of like this hapless kind
of situation that I found myself in and
I tried to make the best of it.
I had a debate once about that with a
friend who was an Asian actor and he was
talking about the lack of roles for
Asians in Hollywood and what a massive
issue is and you know that he wanted to
raise awareness of it.
And I was like,
man,
but this,
we're talking about a creative venture.
You're talking about somebody writing a
story.
Like I think the correct way to go about
it is to try to figure out how to get
your own project through or someone else
who feels very strongly about this.
Trying to get their on project through,
but the right way is not for someone to
have to compromise their creative vision
in order to encompass the full spectrum
of races in whatever story they're
writing.
Like creative story.
Like if you want to write a story about
a small town in Maine,
like Stephen King has done so often,
you shouldn't have to have 10 percent
Asians in that story.
I mean,
you just,
that's not what creativity is about.
It's about,
uh,
there,
there are places and people and the way
you're going to run into all black folks
or were you going to run into all
Norwegian people?
I mean,
in those stories are just as valid as a
story that's fully diverse,
you know?
No,
I don't think that that necessarily
makes anything better.
And I also think that when you're
talking about that,
you're sort of talking about it.
Like there should be a quota,
you know,
and like Hollywood should recognize the
need for these people to be in films and
movies and it's just,
you,
you're,
you're making this politically correct
sort of,
um,
be passing these,
these judgements on this thing that is
all about imagination.
I mean,
Hollywood essentially.
Like what,
when you're making a television show,
are you making a movie is really about
an imagination.
It's about imagination and vision and
having that vision being entertaining
for people and if you like,
only want to write about the people that
you were in college with,
you were that you shared a dorm room
with you should be out aloud to and if
there's a disproportionate amount of
people that are doing that,
that happened to be white males that we
should probably try to figure out why,
but the idea that you have to force
people to hire Asian folks or black
folks or women or whatever.
That's.
That seems so crazy to me.
Serve the story.
Right,
and to give you a little glimpse,
to give you some context with what might
be going on in gaming.
There was this very popular game series
called the Witcher,
which is made by a Polish developer
called CD project.
I'm there in Warsaw and it's based on
the fusion of like Polish kind of
identity with this famous book series
that's based on like kind of Polish or
you know,
like kind of the Lord of the rings,
but in Eastern Europe and one guy is
cartoon character that works at this
website called Polygon.
In his review was talking about how uh,
there were no,
there was no diversity there and
everyone's like,
dude,
it's Poland and it's based on Poland of
your life and it's about dragons and
like goblins and there's some white guys
and this is like what you're upset
about,
you know,
and there's another guy making it and I
think he's Slovakia and I don't want to.
Somewhere in eastern Europe making a
game called kingdom come deliverance and
it's supposed to be very realistic.
Look at something like the 14th or 15th
century in that area.
And again,
the,
they're complaining,
there's no diversity,
there's no diversity.
And he's like,
there was no black people in this area
in 1500.
I'm trying to make a game that's true to
the air.
Does that,
that doesn't make him a racist.
And,
and these are the kinds of.
This is just the kind of bullshit.
That's why.
But you see this in movies,
you see this in TV shows.
It's,
it's not exclusive to gaming,
but it's.
But it's what I've had to deal with for
a long time.
And I'm just looking at the root of it
though,
what,
what's causing it?
Like why,
why do people feel like they have to put
a black person in a game about Poland in
the 15 hundreds or whatever it was.
I think,
I mean,
I don't.
Thankfully,
the people that make the games don't
care,
you know,
like they're,
they're like,
we're going to make our game,
right?
The people that are complaining about
it,
there are virtuous virtue signaling,
which is not even a term I even knew
what it meant until a few weeks ago.
Like,
I heard people throw that term around.
I didn't quite know what a man I looked
at it,
I looked into it.
It's,
you know,
and you know what it is.
It's the idea that these virtuous
people,
it's the same people that attacked me
for the joke.
I have to be virtuous and show that I am
against sexism.
So I have to attack the man.
You know,
I have to do all these kinds of things
in this need,
you know?
But what they're saying,
when they,
when they're saying we have to have
black people in this game,
in eastern Europe in the 15 hundreds,
what they're saying,
what they're really saying is,
you're a racist.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the subtext.
And it goes back to this character
assassination in this need to destroy.
Um,
I often use the example of you.
Do you remember when Gawker wrote about
Conde Nast as a CFO and outed them?
No,
I don't know what that story is.
So sad story,
but it's so on Gawker.
This guy wrote this story about,
uh,
the CFO of Conde Nast.
What does that.
Conde Nast is like this big conglomerate
that owns a bunch of,
uh,
like,
you know,
smaller businesses.
They're,
they're pretty big company.
I don't know.
I think they,
I think they might even be in
publishing,
stuff like that.
Okay.
And,
uh,
so they wrote this story and the entire
crux of the story.
This guy that.
No one,
this guy,
I think his brother or brother in law
with Timothy Geithner.
So that's his,
that's his claim to fame I guess,
but he's just a private citizen that
works as a cfo of a big corporation.
They write this piece,
that outcome as a gay man that he's
having or trying to have an affair
behind.
His wife's back with this guy,
all of this stuff just.
And I'm like,
I read this piece.
I'm like,
what is the purpose of this?
Why?
And I'm sure Jamie,
if you want to,
you can probably find it.
I did the why did they write it?
I'm clicks,
you know,
and,
and it actually blew up in their faces.
People are fucking furious about this
because this wasn't yet.
So the,
there's the uh,
the thing,
it's like they just out this guy for no
reason to steroid his life.
Gawker on Thursday evening helped as
Grunfeld sex worker,
extort the chief financial officer at
Conde Nast and brother,
a former treasury,
treasury secretary,
Kim Geitner that has his name.
Tim Geithner.
Yep.
Jensen,
ing.
Any semblance of journalistic integrity
and likely ruining a man's life in the
process.
I'm telling you,
you can go jump down the rabbit hole
this read about this guy.
This is such an example of outrage of
not even.
I already told you I've just character
assassination for sake to remember this.
Now I'm kind of remembering the story.
It's almost,
it's unfortunate.
There's so many fucking crazy stories.
So it's,
yeah,
it says,
uh,
he is married and has three children
allegedly arrange a night with a male
escort.
On a recent trip to Chicago when the
escort found out who the CFO was,
he asked for help with an ongoing
housing dispute.
In other words,
trying to kick it to the government
because of his connection with Geitner
CFO.
Allegedly,
he got spooked and canceled their
meeting,
though he paid in full for the,
for whatever rendezvous they were going
to have in retaliation.
The escort went to Gawker,
which published the story despite
knowing that doing so would play into
the extortion attempts.
The site also publish screenshots of the
pairs,
alleged text message exchange,
including several photos.
They shook this guy down and ruined him,
ruined him,
ruined you.
Probably he's going to have problems
with his wife,
probably get the forest now.
His kids are going to be in limbo.
He's gonna lose his job and he's got to
follow them around forever.
Why?
Right.
Because he tried to,
you know,
it's not our business if he's cheating
on his wife and it's not our business.
If he's gay and it's our business,
if he's trying to have him be with a
male escort,
they saw clickbait.
Yup.
And this is,
and this is what it's all about.
It's to say I would even go further with
Gawker,
which obviously ended up taking him down
with Hulk Hogan.
It's like,
why?
Because he's a famous person to his sex
tape,
which is going to ruin his friendship,
ruined his marriage and all of these
connections.
What kind of pleasure do you get out of
that?
That goes back to the point I was making
about how I wouldn't write stories about
a couple people back in the day because
I didn't want to ruin them.
That's not what I'm out to do and I feel
like that.
So it all plays into the same culture,
the same culture of character
assassination,
Neil puritanism,
witch hunting,
enjoying irresponsibility.
There's a responsibility that comes with
this that there's almost like a power
that has not been earned.
This the power of whether it's social
media,
whether it's the ability to write blogs
about someone like that or whether it's
ability to,
uh,
just to,
to make tweets and just a attack,
someone that this,
this,
this ability is really very,
very new and the ability to mass
published,
like to make a tweet about a guy like
you just decide Collin Moriarty is a
piece of shit.
I can't believe that joke fucking
sexist.
And then boom,
put that out there.
And then it gets retweeted over and
over again like that.
People don't necessarily understand the
repercussions of these actions that this
is like there,
there's,
there's an amount of power that they
really haven't earned.
This amount of power and influence that
you,
that you have in your ability to express
yourself today.
That's a really new thing.
I look at it a little differently in the
sense that.
Because I think you're right,
I think you're onto something there,
but I think it's also the mob mentality
that it's,
that exposes the fact that say I was
ruined forever.
Right?
And they won whatever that means.
And then people go like,
hey,
you just ruin that guy.
Why did you do that?
And they'd be like,
oh,
he did it.
Oh,
He did.
In other words,
no one's responsible for it.
And when you're,
when you're in this mob,
it's like,
it's like it's,
it's old fashioned witch hunting and
it's done for strangely puritanical
reasons.
That's.
Do you think that there's also an
inclination to do it because you're
worried that it's going to happen to you
and you want to attack first feel like
there's almost a thing where the people
want to take the,
the,
the vision off of themselves or they,
they want to take the,
the,
the scrutiny of themselves point.
And when you pointed at someone else
enough and you keep pointing at other
people,
they.
I mean eventually people kind of get it
after awhile,
but like is that a little expression
that if you want to look at like the
with,
with girls,
it was always like the girls who would
talk shit about other girls being sluts
were always the biggest slots.
Right.
You know,
I mean there's this weird thing about
people where if you're going after folks
and a lot of those sort of situations,
what you're trying to do is take some of
the eyes off of you.
I think that that's probably a huge
element of it.
I find it strange because I went about
my business in a different way for the
same reason,
if that makes any sense.
So it's like I don't want to.
You're making the argument,
which I think is true that it's like
don't pay attention to the man behind
the curtain.
Like there's all of this stuff over
there and my whole thing was like,
I don't want to be involved in this,
get that,
get that.
And I believe you that you don't want to
be involved in that.
And I think that's very virtuous.
I think it's very nice that you think
the way you do,
I think it's important,
um,
and I think it's important that you,
you have this ability to express
yourself and let people know that that
is a good way to look at the,
the least amount of conflict that you
can go through life with the better
you're going to be off as long as it's
in unnecessary conflict.
You know,
and I think in this situation,
this is clearly unnecessary conflict.
Yeah.
And,
and that's the,
that's the whole it.
And it causes this,
this rigorous kind of atmosphere where
we can see it in politics to where
everyone's mad about everything.
Like Donald trump reads everyone's mad.
Donald Trump read the day,
uh,
the,
the picture that's going around on CNN
and where it's like,
it was literally like,
is Donald Trump afraid of stairs?
Was like the Kyron the lower third.
And it's like,
and it's like stairs and it's like furs
elevators.
Yeah.
He prefers gilded elevators,
but that they're,
they're serious.
Real question.
This is,
yeah,
this is the kind of stuff that's going
on.
And so when you say s,
t a I r or s,
t,
no,
stairs,
you walk up and down and down and the
ars because it can be like the evil
eyes.
But uh,
to me I'm like,
uh,
you know,
and that's why it goes,
the,
the fact
is,
and I think this is an important
component to maybe making you understand
what happened a little bit better
because you're not in the,
in that ecosystem,
but I think you can relate because
you're seeing it happen elsewhere,
is that the gaming media is dying and
they're dying because no one really
trusts or cares.
Trust them or cares what they have to
say anymore.
People.
Ten year olds and 15 year olds today are
not growing up being like,
I wonder what polygon has to say about
the newest game.
They go to youtube and find a guy there
that they trust and believe,
which is why the only people unanimously
pretty much that came out in my defense
where you tubers,
because they know that they're the next
rung of this evolution of the way we
absorb and communicate and absorb
information.
And have news meanwhile these people to
your point or writing,
clickbait,
trying to stay relevant,
but no one really cares what they're
saying anyway,
so they're in their death throws.
This is a way for them to take shots at
multiple people at the same time.
This is what they did,
a Pewdie Pie.
This is what they did to other people
and put pie.
One was really egregious.
It was agreed to split.
But like again,
a lot of that stuff was taken out of
context and a lot of auto mean.
Pewdiepie always agreed the attacks on
him.
Oh,
it was terrible what Wall Street Journal
did to him.
This is just the sign of the Times.
These are people fighting and I really
feel this way and you might disagree,
but I feel like a lot of it is these
people are fighting for their lives.
If I were,
if I were a person that was trending up,
hold on a journalist.
The journalist.
Yeah.
Like if I were.
I'm sorry to to interrupt you.
If I were right,
if I had written in the video game
industry for 10 years,
right.
I wrote the gaming industry for 14
years,
but how is a 10 year industry veteran
and I had fewer than 10,000 twitter
followers and I'm writing for a site.
No one reads and I'm trying my hardest
to stay relevant and to do my thing.
I'd be pretty mad too if I saw a guy
that turns on his camera and speaks
whatever he wants and gets the amount of
views in 30 minutes,
then I'll get the entire year.
Why would you be men?
Because it's nothing to do with you,
but what does it has a lot to do with
you because there's only so much time
and space for these people to absorb
things and they'd rather famine
mentality.
They'd rather go to youtube.
Three hundred and $50.
Million people in this country alone and
there's many,
many more people over over the world.
The idea that anybody's views is somehow
or another taking away from your views.
It was just straight famine mentality.
Has plenty of eyes to go around and
you're showing it right now with your
new project.
Sure.
But I'm just like.
But I'm just saying like their.
Their thought process sucks.
Yeah,
and extensively it's actually adding to
their destruction because people are
looking at this like the media for
instance,
in political and the political landscape
is dying anyway that the decline is
happening.
Wall Street Journal put up a piece not
too long ago saying that per capita of
viewership on television is actually
starting to be outpaced by youtube.
So that's over now.
Right.
So like now that's not on video online
or video on demand.
That's just youtube.
And so people are looking at the
situation and actually precipitated that
happening quicker because in order to
stay relevant they lie.
Are they pieces?
I think we should talk about what
happened with [inaudible].
Most people are like,
who the fuck is put shy and what
happened?
Sure.
Do you want me to send it to you have to
do is so pewdie pie is,
is the biggest youtuber in the world.
He has 55 million subscribers and he's a
millionaire.
I'm just to be clear,
I've never,
I don't really know him very well.
I think I've had one or two communicates
with him at some point,
but,
um,
I don't know.
Um,
so I don't really have a horse in the
race.
Uh,
he lives in Europe.
He lives in England,
I think he's Swedish or something of
that nature,
but he lives in England and he has a
massive youtube following me in every
video he does.
We'll have 10,
12,
15 million views and you know,
you're on youtube.
I'm on youtube and a much lesser sense
that's a lot of use.
And he pushed the boundaries in some
ways and some tasteless ways as this is
right.
And the thing that really caught on was
that he was using this,
this app or this,
this,
this service called Fiverr,
which is this kind of task rabbit kind
of thing where it's like you can pay
people to do whatever you want,
any paid.
Some of the things he did were
otherwise,
but he paid these guys and some country
to hold up these,
uh,
like death to all Jews signs or
something like that as part of a joke.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
and that's something I think is somewhat
tasteless,
but he's trying to make a point,
whatever point he was trying to make,
he's trying to make a point.
It was lost on a lot of people and this
combined with some other imagery he had
been using some kind of fascist or Nazi
imagery and some other things that have
been going on over the months.
I'm sorry,
did you want.
Oh,
you about to say something.
I'm sorry.
And uh,
so eventually the Wall Street Journal
caught wind of this Wall Street Journal
obviously have a prolific right of
center,
but still pretty moderate newspaper.
Um,
and basically went after,
been tried to basically tried to destroy
him and took a lot of things out of
context.
Then forced Disney's Disney owns a
studio that funds him and all these
kinds of things and caused a lot of
personal and economic destruction for
this.
It seems like they intentionally took
things out of context too,
and they distorted the actual intent of
what he was trying to do,
especially with telling people to not be
Nazis.
He was mocking people that were being
Nazis and they used that to say,
this guy is pretending to be a Nazi.
Right.
It was a completely dishonest hit piece
in the same vein as the conde nast hit
the same vein as the whole Cogan head is
the same.
It's,
it's,
it's these people,
they know the term punching up.
They want to punch up and they think
they're punching up Wall Street
Journal's punching up now on youtube
years,
but really caused a lot hilarious
punching up on a youtuber.
That's the way they look at it as not an
awareness.
It is.
This guy's a youtuber.
He's a guy by himself.
You're punching up to attack him because
he's the king because he's the media
elite.
I mean that's the media elite.
I mean it's like an independent reporter
attacking the ABC news or something like
that.
Exactly.
And,
and to me it was like,
it showed a lot of cowardice.
It showed a lot of half cocked thinking
on there on the Wall Street Journal's
part to think that this was going to
blow back on them and it showed a level,
and I hate using this word because I
don't think innately it's necessarily a
bad thing because I think it drives you
forward,
but there's a level of jealousy at play
with a lot of these kinds of things that
are happening.
What you were thinking about before when
you were saying that someone who is
struggling to get 10,000 views and a
story they write is going to look at a
guy like this that can do one video
where he talks about farts and he makes,
you know,
his 7 million views or something like
that.
He makes 15 million a year or whatever
and they're met and they don't
understand it.
And I get that.
You know,
I look at some people that are famous
are some that are,
you know,
have a platform and I'm like,
I don't get this,
but I'm not going to like sit here and
like rain on their parade.
That's their right.
They have an audience that's totally
fine.
Maybe look at yourself and why you don't
have an audience.
Maybe you look at yourself and realize
that you have you been doing this for so
long and you're so proud of that.
Why isn't anyone listening to you?
Could it be you,
you know,
instead of instead of looking around for
people to assassinate,
which is what's basically happening
here.
Uh,
I just,
I find it's so distasteful.
I find it's so destructive.
We're at the precipice of a very
dangerous time because the,
the trust in institutions,
no matter where you are now is just lost
and a lot of it has to do.
And,
and uh,
that's what I was saying with media
precipitating the fall by not telling
the truth by not doing the right thing.
I think the media in terms of pull it
politics for instance,
is really rebounding from the fact that
they thought Clinton was gonna win.
So they thought they can get away with
saying and doing anything for that means
to an end.
The Donna Brazil,
for instance,
where she was feeding questions to the
Clinton campaign is so incredible.
So shows such a level of bias and
systemic inherent bias.
They thought they were going to get away
with all of it.
Now no one trusts anyone.
So when I see all this stuff,
I don't know what's going on with Russia
and trump for all I know he could be a
fucking Manchurian candidate,
you know,
but I don't believe a word they say,
like when I read this about Paul
Manafort about Flynn about blah blah
blah,
blah blah.
I'm like,
I don't know.
You will have about all this other shit.
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
You know,
I have to really do my own research.
I don't even know who to trust anymore.
They did that to themselves and they
precipitated their own downfall.
More and more people are going on
youtube to listen to people like you,
to listen to people.
Even like Alex Jones.
So listen to Dave Rubin to listen to
that problem.
It is a problem because usually if you
listened in to me,
well you,
it's a problem because you need people
in the trenches that you trust.
You need someone in the press room at
the White House,
you need someone in the app that is on
the wire,
that is telling you the truth,
but when you can't even trust them
anymore,
right?
That's a big problem and that's when
people go seek out alternative sources
of news and information and
entertainment and that's what's
happening and that's why they're dying.
Yeah.
Well,
in many ways that you sure that big
corporate model is in ensuring their own
demise.
Absolutely,
and and it's,
it's the race for clicks.
It's the race for money.
It's the race for prominence.
That's the race for relevance
and not honesty,
not transparency and not a real
objective sense of what the truth is and
what the actual facts of a story are.
That's where journalism is a different
thing now because it's now a
entertainment show.
It's an entertainment show that also has
the news in it,
but that's why the women are so hot.
That's why the women on Fox News are
wearing these tiny little dresses and
they have beautiful legs and heels on
and they're talking about important
issues,
but they're giving you a little bit an
Icandy why?
So transparency.
What I see,
that kind of stuff.
I'm like,
it was a very attractive woman.
I'm sure she knows what she's talking
about,
but I know why.
I know why she sits at the end of the
table.
I liked when they were,
they're aggressive
to look Megan Kelly,
she's attractive and she's aggressive.
She's smart.
That's what makes her sexy.
Yeah.
Talking about,
but uh,
you know.
Yeah.
So we're,
we're in this,
we're in this weird space,
you know,
we're in.
This is just very bizarre space.
Do you feel like this is like an almost
an period in human communication that
we're going through this weird growth
period where we're,
we have this incredible access to
information and the ability to spread it
like we have now with social media and
with youtube and all these different
things where anybody can kind of hop in
and all of a sudden get a platform like
this pd peg guy.
Pewdie pie wasn't a star,
it wasn't a politician.
He wasn't an actor before this.
It was just a guy and he connected with
people and carved out this path for
himself and pretty much anybody can kind
of do that now.
I mean there's.
It's not easy.
It's not.
If it was easy,
everyone would do it,
but it is not insurmountable and I
wonder what the next stage is in terms
of the ability to share information if
it's going to change past where it's at
now and get to some new level.
Yeah,
I think.
I think you're right in the sense that
the Internet specifically had taken off
so quickly.
The World Wide Web is only 24 years old.
The Internet's way older,
but the way we communicate with each
other now is so different than even use
net in the eighties or these kind of
university university communications
that they had going on in the seventies
where they were sharing things with
amongst each other.
You don't need gatekeepers anymore.
There are no gatekeepers.
You can go start a youtube channel now,
find an audience,
gain thousands subscribers,
make a lot of money and say what you
want,
um,
and that's scary to the traditional
gatekeepers and they don't like it and
they're there for the fight against that
is so transparent and it's so self
serving when I don't,
we need a media that we can trust,
but I don't think we need the media as
it is right now either because the media
we have right now is bloated,
dishonest Po,
a partisan,
politically motivated.
All of these things that don't really
serve a purpose to educating and
informing some of the days of cronkite
are gone.
Well.
Doesn't that sort of set the stage for
someone to come in and offer a viable
alternative?
I hope so.
There you are calling moriarty.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the idea.
It's just in my own way like I don't,
I don't have these delusions of grandeur
that I'm going to make millions of
dollars and have this huge reach already
at $39,000 a month.
You better cut the shit with this
humility stuff.
I just,
I don't know what you're doing.
Know what you're doing.
You fuck stop.
I've just,
I'm just trying to say that I didn't
have,
I left my
making good money.
I own,
you know,
a kind of funny I,
I walked away expecting that I was going
take a pay cut to do what I really
wanted to do and try to do the right
thing and uh,
it's great that people are responding
the way they do.
I hope they continue to respond this way
because it will allow us to do more,
more of it.
My advice to you,
stop being concerned with that and just
do the best of stopped being concerned
with being humble about all this and it.
So it's definitely gonna drop.
It's definitely I'm going to make.
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not going to be payments.
I'm not going to be.
Forget about all that nonsense.
Well,
it's all like you're shackled yourself.
Just I'm just trying out forward young
man.
I appreciate [inaudible] forward with
intent.
You've got some good content,
man.
You're appreciated.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it so much.
My pleasure,
man,
and thanks for coming on here,
man.
It was a good time.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
I really appreciate you doing.
You do have a thing and it's.
It does go live in April.
I'd be happy to help you promote it and
happy to have you back on again and it
was really awesome.
Really enjoyed this.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you calling moriarity.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back in a little while with my
friend Justin wren.
See you soon.
Bye.
Was Great.
Thank you.
That was a lot of fun.